Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
Now it does seem like
I'm a cybernetic organism,
living tissue over.
So it is brought to you by a new sponsor.
So listen up folks.
This is a good one because have you ever
wanted to be as powerful as a bullet
wearing Ninja from an 1980s movie or as
flamboyant as big gay Al Big Al in south
park or a sleek as a black panther
in the Amazon on the hunt wealth?
There's great news because I've been
testing this product that you wrap around
your genitals and it makes you feel
like a superhero and it is called
[inaudible].
I've spent the last two to three weeks
traveling with underwear from these guys
and they are comfy.
I gotta tell you,
it feels like a Geisha has giving your
groin a hug and it's not just for dudes.
But if you go to [inaudible] dot com
forward slash Tim, that's m, e, e, u n, d,
I e s.com forward slash.
Tim,
you can see all of the underwear
that I've been wearing.
There's some pretty ridiculous ones. And
uh, I will also highlight my favorite,
you'll probably be able
to guess which it is.
These underwear made from micro Medallia,
which is extruded from Austrian
beechwood trees in the Alps. Yes. Fancy.
And it's two times softer than cotton,
scientifically tested using the
[inaudible] method developed in Kyoto.
And you know, those Japanese very
crafty. And uh, I will say a few things.
Number one, if you go to me on
these.com forward slash Tim,
you get to see all of these spectacular
underwear that I've been wearing and I
am a bit of an underwear connoisseur,
socks, fashion, sense with sweatpants,
not so much underwear. I
understand. So check them out.
And if you go to [inaudible]
dot com forward slash Tim,
you will also be able to see lots
of hot ladies wearing me undies,
female underwear.
And that's just a lot of goodness for
both the men and the women out there.
So check it out.
[inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim,
I love these underwear and a,
I'm going to be packing tonight probably
six to 12 pair to take with me to
Australia. They're great. Check em out.
[inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim
the Tim Ferriss show is
brought to you by on it.
I have used on IT products for years.
If you look in my kitchen in my garage,
you will find Alpha brain chewable
Melatonin for resetting my clock when I'm
traveling. Kettlebells, battle
ropes, maces steel clubs.
It sounds like a torture
chamber and it kind of is.
It's a torture chamber for
self improvement and you
can see all of my favorite
gear at [inaudible] dot com
forward slash Tim that's o,
n n I t.com forward slash Tim and
you can also get a discount on any
supplements, food products. I like
hemp force, I like Alpha brain.
Check it all out on
it.com forward slash Tim.
Hello my dangerous dainty friends.
This Tim Ferriss,
and this is another episode of the Tim
Ferriss Show where I try my best to
deconstruct excellence and
world class performers.
That means interviewing people
who are the best at what they do,
or one of the best of what
they do, whether they're
investors or chess, prodigies,
actors, athletes, everyone in,
anyone who fits the bill of top performer.
I will try to dig into the habits,
the routines,
the favorite books, the meals, the
mule timing, their sleep habits,
meditation techniques and so on and so
forth to provide you with recipes that
you can test.
So not a whole bunch of
Highfalutin abstract concepts,
although we explore some deep stuff.
But the really tactical tools
that you can implement on a daily,
weekly basis to become better at
whatever you do or want to do.
And this episode is no exception.
We have Whitney Cummings,
so Whitney is hilarious.
Whitney is a Los Angeles based
comedian, actor, writer and producer.
She's a multihyphenate.
And uh,
let me rattle off just a few things.
Uh,
she's executive producer end along with
Michael Patrick King cocreator of the
Emmy nominated CBS comedy.
Two broke girls not to
broke curls are a lot of ks,
two broke girls. You've
probably seen it, heard of it,
observed the advertisements for
it. It's all over the place. Uh,
which was recently picked up for
a fifth season. She also wrote,
produced and starred in Whitney,
which aired on NBC from
2011 to 2013 not only that,
outside of television she has headlined
with comics including Sarah Silverman,
Louie Ck, Amy Schumer, Aziz
Ansari and many others.
Lots of big names.
She's famous for some other skills that
will explore like roasting other comics
and celebrities.
That is a fascinating and fun conversation
that we dug into her first one hour
stand up,
special money shot,
premiered on comedy central and 2010
and was nominated for an American comedy
award. Her second standup
special Whitney Cummings.
I love you debuted on comedy central and
2014 and she is shooting a third hour
for HBO this August,
which is set to air in 2016 in this
conversation and we talk about her process
for writing both comedy and other types
of writing difference between fiction
and nonfiction, we get really granular
on how she develops her jokes.
I asked her questions like, if you had
eight weeks to take someone, I, he,
me who's terrified of standup,
no experience to get them ready for a
real performance, what would those a week,
eight weeks of training look like?
And we also turn back the clock,
look at her childhood,
look at the things that have formed her
and informed her of the mistakes that
she's made, managing other
people, Lessons learned, uh,
because she's had massive teams, hundreds
of people, which I did not know. Uh,
and we even delve into some very esoteric
stuff like equine therapy using horses
for therapeutic work. Really
fascinating. I love this conversation.
I hope you do as well.
And she is,
I've added funding lady making me laugh.
So I hope you enjoy Whitney Cummings.
And I usually say without further ado,
Whitney Cummings,
but I've said when he come, he was
like 17 times already in this intro.
So Whitney cat makes Whitney Cummings,
Whitney Cummings like Candyman enjoy
Whitney. Dear, thank you so much for
being on the show. Thank you sir.
Like I caught you opening your beaches.
Look, I'm really into beverages. I
don't know if you noticed this about me.
It's my weird collection. I think I'm a
hoarder. Uh, I'm really into hydrating,
but like sneakily sell like nefarious
hydration. It can never be actual water.
It's always like something just a,
they cost $8.
Right? We'll beat you us of, and a lot
of endurance athletes are big on beaches.
That's what I'm here to tell you.
I said I've made my transition into
being an intern. That's my new,
that's why you were grilling. Yep. Yeah.
Like American Ninja Warrior competitor
who wandered water to the living room.
Some of your questions and uh,
yeah.
Yeah, no, I um,
I feel like I didn't make a lot of great
health decisions in my early twenties
so I feel like I'm overcompensating
now with, you know, things like this
better than going the other
direction right here. Like,
you know, I was so healthy,
I was so orthorexic I
was competitive athletes.
I feel like our parents just
kind of dropped the ball. I mean,
now that we know so much about
GMOs and high fructose corn syrup,
I feel like I'm like on borrowed time.
Well,
I think that maybe they dropped the ball,
but they didn't know they were carrying
the ball in the first place or percent.
Yes. They didn't know that they
have plausible deniability. Right.
That'd be like a saw my fault that I gave
you chicken mcnuggets so why I smoked
when I was pregnant. Krispy Kreme. Oh,
exactly. The fruity pebbles every morning
go pubs here, right. Breakfast,
lunch and dinner. Um,
so I feel like I'm kind of like trying
to rectify a lot of that damage that was
done.
So, oh, look at this. I
just noticed. So I love you.
How is that on your arm?
And I've got that for you.
I have something else to tell you.
Pull of the exciting
confessions right off the bat
that you just said, uh, because as,
um, what you guys can't see, hopefully,
unless you're Weirdo Stalker,
I have a white tattoo on my lower left
forearm that says I love you and I don't
think anyone has ever noticed it without
me having to point it out. How is that?
That's so interesting. Reduce. I have
another white one right here. Uh, oh yeah.
It's an anchor. Um, be, it's basically,
this is like someone who's
incredibly commitment phobic,
who wants a tattoo but doesn't want
anybody to see it. Um, so that's, yeah,
so that's
one of my weaknesses.
But is it,
is it done with an electric needle
without any ink? Nope. With white ink,
but it has to go much
deeper. So it's more like scarification
so basically hurts like twice.
So I am fascinated by that.
Twice as much pain,
but half the recognition sounds
like a lot of business ideas.
I've had worst investment Basel. Okay.
The, that's fascinating to me because
I've never seen a tattoo like that before.
But I read when I was in
Japan as an exchange student,
my first time abroad when I was 15,
I became obsessed with Yakuza tattoos
and sort of deep traditional tattoos that
were associated with organized crime.
And I read about this type of Tattoo,
which is pretty much exactly
what you have on your arm.
They would only become visible when the
skin was flush at, say, the public baths.
Wow.
So if they wanted to keep it under wraps
that they were organized crime member,
but then wanted to scare the shit out of
everybody when they're in naked in the
baths. Wow. You'll have
like full back white tech.
That is so cool. It's almost like
black light tattoos today or something.
I don't even know what a
black with a black light,
you can do a black light tattoo.
This is mostly for,
I guess people who do Lsd
and did like special k,
but you can do it with black light ink so
you can only see it in her black lives.
This gotta be good for you.
Yeah.
This is so funny because I wrote my senior
honors thesis in college on Tattooing.
Really?
Yeah.
So I've, uh, no, I think you
also have, if I saw correctly,
something on the back of
one of your arms. Yes, yes.
I have a safety pin on
the back of my right arm,
which I always forget I have because I
hid it so well that I always forget it's
there. But what is the story of the
safety pins? Safety pin is sort of um, uh,
well the I love you is first uh,
for you Tim.
Thank you. I wanted to subtly, it's
really a requirement for podcast guests.
This is what I have it really divulged
sign the release. You get the Tattoo,
then we can talk. Right, right.
I've been Brandon, um, I got the,
well let me do them in order. I got
the anchor right here. I'm on my wrist.
Michael Patrick King and I created
a show called two broke girls,
which is on CBS. Michael Patrick
King, you know, did sex in the city.
If you had a girlfriend at the time
you probably had to watch it. Uh,
he did a show called the comeback,
which is a brilliant show.
It is so well done.
I'm sort of about an aging actress in
Hollywood and sexism in Hollywood and it's
just, it's just incredibly well
written and performed and a,
we did two broke girls together, a
simultaneous, I was doing a show on NBC,
which was a Sitcom as well as a talk show.
So I was doing three shows simultaneously,
which doing one is already going to say
glutton for punishment, Herculean task.
So, um, so I was just, I
was having a hard time, um,
I dealt with some just, you
know, as a comedian, you know,
you become a comedian because you
want people to like you, you know,
and then all of a sudden you're sort
of thrust into the zeitgeists is like a
public figure and then, you know,
not everyone's gonna like you,
which in standup is usually a good
thing because that means you're being
specific, you know, as you, I believe,
say, uh, when you try to please everybody,
you please no one. Right. Exactly. So the
idea is you want to polarize some people,
but then all of a sudden
its critics are like,
wait a second and then you recreate your
childhood circumstances and you're like,
Dad,
I mean,
critics just become your dad who won't
accept you or your mom whose approval
you're trying to get. So you just sort
of time travel back and to being a kid.
And so that was really hard
on me. And then, uh, I just
kind of eviscerated myself.
I did everything wrong in terms of
being a boss and managing my time and
managing people's Egos
and depleting myself,
which I've learned a lot in the last
thing you were working on when I was
working on these three shoes, I was the
perfect example of what to never do.
This is before I knew about
you before I, you know, had a,
I'm in a 12 step program for
codependence called Alanen. Uh,
and I do trauma therapy now.
I do all this stuff, whatever.
But this was before I had any kind of
that recovery or had done any work on my
sort of neuropathways.
I was using a lot of really old survival
skills and I was like people pleasing
and caretaking and I couldn't fire anyone
and I was terrified to tell someone no
and I couldn't have uncomfortable
conversations and uh,
I was all of a sudden the boss of
like 400 people and I, it's a lot,
it's a lot of people.
I was not the number x three different
show I've worked on big TV shows,
a TV show. It is very,
very minimal. 400 people.
It's a lot of people too. I mean it
was just between three different shows.
I have three staffs, 200 each, you know,
it was probably more like
600 over the year. Um,
and they're all looking to you for
clarity and being decisive and just saying
yes or no instead of well, I just,
I feel like I'm so sorry. It just,
I was so apologetic and so, you know,
desperate for everyone's approval, um,
which makes a great comedian,
terrible boss. And uh,
and so I was just having a really hard
time and I remember Michael Patrick King,
who's sort of one of my mentors, he gave
me a ring that had a, a anchor on it.
Just sort of that, you know, who's like,
just stay grounded, stay in your shoes.
Because anytime someone would come would
come to me, I would just like abandoned,
you know,
myself and just jump out of my skin to
try and take care of them and manage them
and please them instead of just
keeping my feet on the ground.
And then of course, I
promptly lost the ring. Uh,
so I decided to get the tattoo
of it in white of course,
because being on television,
you have to go in like an hour
early to get tattoos covered.
And I don't want to give up, you know,
an hour a day, five hours of my week.
That's five minutes. That's it,
right. Every, yeah. Every, you know,
an hour a day times five days
a week. Yeah. That's, you know,
five hours of tattoo covering, which I
just don't have time. So hence the white.
And then the safety pin was
sort of, um, I grew up in,
this is not funny and we're
going to get funny. Uh,
and you kind of to be in kind of
an unsafe environment. And, uh,
my parents would argue a lot when I
was a kid and I used to play with,
we didn't have a lot of money.
I was poor safety pins where my toys,
I just remember playing with safety pins
and I remember opening them and closing
them. And I just remember that was
just, I did Emdr, which is like a, um,
a trauma thing, movement,
eye movement, uh,
deeper desensitized desensitization.
You can say that word station
and reprogramming. Got It.
Involves eye movements
for overcoming trauma or sure.
Basically Reprogram your trauma in terms
of putting them into putting a trauma
to a different folder,
like in layman's terms.
So the way that my trauma
therapist explained it to me was,
you remember the episode and I love Lucy
when there was the conveyor belts. Sure.
Of was it the bon bons or
was it bottles with gloves?
I want to see it was bottles.
I want to say it was bottles and
she was putting the glove on it.
That was in the open.
But anyways,
so she explains it as our brains taken 3
billion pieces of information a second.
Right. So, you know, Tim shirt is,
you know, camouflage and how he feels,
how he looks, how this house
feels, trampoline outside.
That's the longer story.
Listeners is the trampoline that all I
want to do is leave this podcast to go
jump on it. Um, and, uh, and then when
we get traumatized, her brain freezes.
Uh,
but the information keeps coming in.
So if right now someone came in and
held up a gun to our heads, right,
the information would still come in
white walls, wood in a apple computer,
this cactus, and then it would be
filed into the folder of trauma. Right.
So later in five years,
I'm sitting at dinner and all of a sudden
there's a cactus and I'm anxious and
stressed out and I don't know why
exactly. And I'm triggered, you know,
so it's like reprogramming some of those
triggers into a folder that is more
benign. Got It. Essentially.
And so did the tattoo
come after that Emdr? Yes.
Yes. Got It. Yeah.
When I started doing EMDR and sort
of like getting into sort of like,
um, neurological recovery
essentially from trauma and was the,
was the safety pin a trigger
for negative feelings?
And if so, why did you choose to put
on your arm? That's interesting. It was
kind of my, and it wasn't
necessarily a trigger for me.
I think it was more like a symbol
for me of sort of a time. And the,
I think this is sounds kind of Corny,
but like it was open when I was a kid
and I would sort of like, you know,
not in like a masochistic way,
but I was sort of like pricked
myself with it when things would get,
it was just like a tick kind of like as
someone bites her nails or something.
And so I sort of closed it.
So the tattoo is a closed
safety pen that's sort of
like you're safe. It's over.
Cause a lot of times if you have
any kind of trauma as a kid,
you become an adult and you constantly
are recreating our childhood
circumstances and having
these completely obsolete,
inappropriate feelings to present
situation. So I had, uh, you know,
it was working with somebody who triggered
all these feelings that my family of
origin used to cause.
And it was like,
this is a completely
inappropriate reaction.
This is an employee who works for me,
who's trying to get a scrubbed on and
all of a sudden I'm like, you know,
reliving these historical wounds,
it's not appropriate.
So I think it was a sort of me really
trying to put an end to that story and
respond to present circumstances
with presence, appropriate emotions.
Got It. That makes any sense. It
does make sense. And the I love you.
I love you is um, a couple things. Uh,
my last special was called I love you.
Uh,
but I actually did that
after I got the tattoo. I um,
interesting.
I'm trying to like,
figure out how to say this
without seeming like ridiculous,
but something that I sound ridiculous
sometimes I'm on the podcast, maybe,
you know what I mean? I'm just
admitting like pretty embarrassing.
It's pretty hard to embarrass me,
but this,
but any kind of vulnerability tends
to be a little bit embarrassing for a
comedian.
Um,
I was struggling a little bit
with patience and compassion and,
um, again, I'm codependent or like
I grew up in an alcoholic home,
which a lot of times people get a,
we have a lot of trouble with patients
and control and we want everyone to do
what we want to do when
we want it to be done.
And that's sort of how
we survived as children,
is that if I could just organize
my drinks in the right row,
I'm going to be fine,
you know,
and I found myself and I travel a
tremendous amount as I'm sure you do also,
or, and I have in the past
and I just found myself
getting frustrated with people
not doing things my way.
I don't know if you've ever tasted,
it's like every minute of
every hour of my life. Okay.
So I might have a pamphlet for you.
Yeah. Um, but I found myself just being,
and I think that's one of
the reasons I gravitated,
gravitated towards being a writer and a
comedian is I get to do it all on my own.
Right. You know, I write the material, I
perform it. I critique it, I rewrite it.
I tore, I do everything on my own because
when other people get involved, I just,
you know, it's an efficient, and I
don't like the way you're doing things.
I don't like the way you're saying that.
I don't like the way you're sitting,
like everything.
So
is really a low stress to have 600 people
constantly just working on projects
here.
Exactly. Like it's, you're
wearing flip flops to work.
I mean it was just this like just
a way to not focus on myself.
And I think ultimately sometimes
when we judge other people,
it's just a way to not look at
ourselves as a way to feel superior or
sanctimonious or whatever. So, um,
my trauma therapist said like every time
you meet someone just in your head say
I love you before you have a conversation
with them and that conversation's
going to go a lot better. Cool. I like,
it was just an interesting
little trek for 28 days,
which is how long it takes to make a
neural pathway a new neuropathway. Um,
I would just, uh, when I
meet someone in my head,
whether it's the lady at the DMV
who's making me wait two hours,
and essentially it's just the notion
of everybody is doing the best they can
with what they have. Yeah. Which is
really hard for a lot of us to accept
super hard. This is, I'm
enjoying this because, uh,
I've been trying to work on a lot
of these weaknesses that I have,
which fall pretty squarely right into
the inpatient Dick category and a very
perfectionist.
Yeah.
Very meticulous in sometimes a helpful
detail oriented way oftentimes.
And I like monkish
overbearing way. Yeah. And
great when you're writing a book yourself,
but when all of a sudden you're getting
a relationship or have employees,
it doesn't work as well
or have other people involved in
the process. You become, you know,
a problem author, which is sort
of my label. Yeah. Uh, and there,
there are pros and cons to being a problem
author. You get the cover you want,
but then,
you know,
so and so at the publisher wants to stab
you in the face with the pencil. Right.
Uh, repeatedly and people still use
pencils. I'm not sure, you know,
I'm really clawing my way through a vat
of vocab decaffeinated at the moment.
But, uh, the, um,
two things that are very related
that really helped me were one,
always assuming that people are fighting
battles, you know, nothing about.
Like everyone's fighting some intense
battle internally that you know nothing
about. Number one, okay
thing that is a battle for them might
be super easy for you. Right. You know,
and that's,
I think my dad said something really
who is not known for excellent advice,
but he said something to me,
um,
once that was super helpful because
I was having a lot of trouble in
relationships where I felt like I
wasn't getting my needs met. And uh,
he was like, you just have to
understand how strong you come off.
Like people don't think you need anything.
Right?
So that's why people don't help you.
And it was this interesting
thing where I was like, oh,
I mean I have a lot of weaknesses
and I'm bad at a lot of things,
but when I'm good at something,
which maybe you can relate to,
I'm really good at it, right? Because
I've just worked really hard at it.
So I'm really good at things that a lot
of people might not be and vice versa.
So it's like, I'm like, how come?
Yeah. He hasn't finished that book yet.
How could he ever, it's been two
days. Right. And it's like, okay,
not everyone reads a book or
whatever it is, you know, being,
having compassion for everybody,
right?
Yeah. Not something that comes
naturally to me at least. Uh,
and it's not that I'm a complete like
apathetic serial killer or whatever. It's,
uh,
but the impatience is really pronounced.
One of my favorite quotes, one of my
favorite people is Katherine Hepburn.
And in a Philadelphia story, I think
it was Cary grant said, you, uh,
to Katharine Hepburn's character,
you have no tolerance for human weakness.
And I remember that
resonating a little bit.
Yeah. Which is, it's,
it's easy to rationalize lease. I find
ways to rationalize why it's acceptable,
but you just leave this sort of
string of collateral damage. And, uh,
the, uh, the, the two things that
that brought to mind for me were one,
I remember somebody told me,
you know,
if you walk outside and you go about
your day and you meet an asshole,
that person's an asshole.
If you walk outside and everyone
you meet is an asshole. I love that.
I love that. And so whenever I have
one of those days where I'm like, man,
everybody's so ungrateful and
since they're such assholes,
well,
wait a second now wait a second.
I'm the common denominator in all
these interactions more my problem.
That was exactly. So that was my way
of, uh, just, it's a shortcut and it's,
it's, as soon as I meet someone
in my hat, I just say, I love you.
And then, yeah, I love you. Can I please
get a diet coke with it? Whatever.
I mean forever everybody and a Tsa,
can you please draw my computer?
I'm getting felt up by the TSA
guy. Um, you too. And, well,
I'm Tsa pre now,
that's like third base and I get
it filled up with my shoes on. Um,
and another thing that was super
helpful because at least in my field,
I don't know the case for years,
I can't speak to it,
but a lot of people who
are in a performance based
field, whether it's writing,
acting, um, as, this is
a huge generalization,
but you can sometimes assume they didn't
get a ton of attention as a child or
need more attention than most.
They have a compulsion to be,
need to be seen and heard and appreciated.
And humor is usually developed as
a shield slash defense mechanisms.
So what were they defending against?
We don't know,
but it was something everyone had a thing
they had to defense defend against us
child. My last name is Cummings. That was
probably what I was managing as a child.
Um, and uh, whatever was
going on in my household.
So you get a bunch of really fragile
people who have all these defense
mechanisms in one room to constantly
show up everyday to be rejected because
you're in a writer's room. All you're
doing is pitching and the boss is saying,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
And you're just hearing no all
day. You're not good enough.
You're not funny enough.
Which is what we all translate to.
So much of really fragile,
sensitive people in one room and uh,
who may or may not have done the kind
of recovery that I've committed to our
therapy. We all always just knew everyone
works as hard on ourselves as we do.
They know,
you know.
Well that,
that brings up a couple of things for me.
One is I have at points tried
to chill the fuck out and a,
that takes many forms. Uh,
meditation has been very helpful.
I do have a simple sort of daily morning
meditation practice after two of my
friends were just like, you're being an
idiot. Maybe you should try sitting still.
Uh,
just
I find sitting still and focus,
returning my attention to something,
whether that's breath or a sound or a
word for 20 minutes a day allows me not to
feel overwhelmed.
Yup.
That is due to over responding to things
imaginary or outside of my control.
But what I wonder is for you,
I've sometimes thought, you
know what, I'm impatient,
but I don't want to totally fix it.
I want to dial it back,
but I don't want to totally fix it because
there are a lot of benefits that come
from being impatient.
Sometimes it's a strength in moderation
or sometimes in extremes. I mean,
in the end we could, we could
dig into that. But do you,
do you worry or have you experienced
that doing the work that you've done a,
has negatively impacted your comedy in
any way doing the work I've done has it,
oh, the work I've done,
I see you're removing,
removing the shield or reducing
that codependency. Right.
Has it removed some of the magic?
Great question. Um, I think
the short answer is no.
Uh,
one of my biggest fears when I went
into a recovery program and intensive
therapy,
like not talk therapy like trauma therapy,
which is actually kind of the opposite
of talk therapy because talk therapy
largely I'm not disapproving of
therapy, but for me personally, um,
mine has more of a
neurological perspective,
which is when you have some kind
of trauma and you talk about it,
you just reinvest the trauma and it
actually makes it worse. Right. Um,
so I do like, I can't talk about
a certain topic for 28 days.
I have to replace a negative thought with
a positive thought for 28 days. I mean,
it's like a pretty hard work. I get
really worried. I was like, you know,
talking to my therapist and a bunch
of people in my program, I was like,
I'm just really afraid that I'm not going
to be as funny if I'm not as dark and
in pain all the time.
And it was actually the opposite because
I wasted so much time trying to manage,
you know, unhealthy
relationships and the, you know,
having low self esteem and
my perfectionism, which
can be really paralyzing,
you know, perfect perfectionism
leads to procrastination,
which leads to paralysis.
So I could go a couple of days or like
getting any writing done because my self
esteem was too low.
I didn't think I was good enough and
just these old sort of obsolete messages
and a survival instincts.
And um,
I think that it has given me so much
more mental energy, physical energy. Um,
I have much more balance in my life now
and I'm much more productive and much
more vulnerable, which as a
writer you have to be vulnerable.
I think before I was so overworked,
I was such a chronic workaholic
that I didn't have a life.
And in order for art imitate life,
you have to have a life.
I saw a really profound statement.
For me art was imitating
art because I was,
all I was doing was working turns into
this weird like recursive self reflexive.
Yeah.
And then all of a sudden I'm just in like,
it's just so Mehta and I'm sitting in
there and I remember being in the writer's
room and the second season of a TV
show about sort of relationships and
someone's like, oh, what if they
go to a baby shower? And I'm like,
no one goes to baby showers. And
everyone room was like, you don't,
but most people do on a Sunday, go to a
baby shower. And I was like, oh my God,
I was just so work.
I was so myopic and I was so,
I hadn't had a conversation, you
know, this is going to come off bad,
but I'm just going to be honest,
I haven't had a conversation with
someone that I didn't pay in months. Wow.
Which is scary pay not meaning
you've paid them to talk to you,
but an employee I've been playing.
Yeah. I only talked to though.
No one else is laughing at her script.
The compliments are all
memorize it. But I don't hate
that idea. That's how sick I am.
Um, but yeah, I didn't, I
hadn't had like an organic,
healthy sort of conversation with someone.
Not that the people that I hire are
like obsequious to me and won't walk on
eggshells around me. I have is a
good word. That is a good word. Um,
not bad, not bad. I don't use it often,
but that felt like the right context.
But what I do and comes in with aplomb and
so I felt like, um, you know, it was
really important to me to have balance.
Like I didn't have any hobbies.
Like I had to,
I got assigned homework from my
trauma therapist that I had to do two,
uh,
two hours a week chunks of something
that was purely fun with no work motives
purely. So I took up a equine therapy, um,
and like some other hobbies and stuff,
but it was really a struggle. I was like,
I can do that. And I mean, I
get hour in, I was restless.
I was felled on productive. I felt
like I was making notes in my phone.
I'm like working. I
realized like, Oh my God,
I'm doing bits with horses. What's the
deal or I mean, I was like, it was,
it was a struggle and I mean even like
listening to podcasts or I was always a
motive of like, oh, I can get a joke out
of this or if I listen to it, you know?
And it was,
it made me realize how a work driven I was
the, so going from burning the
candle at both ends, workaholic,
what was the kind of defining moment
where you're like, no more like,
I can't continue this way. What was the
conversation or the day or the experience
by the way in the workaholism and
you know more about this than anyone.
A lot of it was buisiness.
It wasn't actual work.
I was taking on a lot of tasks that I
had no business doing just because I had
been so sort of,
um,
I think one of the most important things
you can do as an artist or in any field,
I can really only speak to Comedians,
actors, writers, performers,
is to get a handle on your issues.
Like both.
You will never be successful if you're
dysfunctional and your relationships and
with your employees and stuff,
if you have trust issues,
if you have abandonment issues, if you're
a narcissist, whatever it is, you know,
um, if you are controlling, because
I found like I remember when I was,
I was so apologetic and I was so
afraid to ask for help that I was doing
everybody's job right, which ends up
disenfranchising them. They get pissed,
they feel micromanaged and
they feel micromanaged.
They feel you can't ultimately
pick up all that slag. Yes.
And I'm exhausting myself and making
them feel bad. No, everybody loses.
And I remember I was like punching
holes in his script and there was like
literally 40 other people in that
room who wanted to do it. I mean,
I just had a bunch of employees that
were like, can we please do something?
Was so bored. And I was like,
I got it. I got it. I was just,
so coming from standup comedy,
I'm so used to doing everything
myself that asking for help,
I realized how hard it was for me.
So there's no point in having a great
script or being a great writer actor if
you can't let people help
you. Um, so I think a lot of,
I realized because again,
being like you and I, um,
just in terms of your, you
know, in patients and all that,
like it works really well
up into a certain point.
So all of these defects had worked
really well for me until I had a staff,
until I had people who were I had to
collaborate with and all of a sudden I'm
like, um, was sort of a codependent mass.
What's wrong with you people? Oh wait,
I know, why does it if you were all
just psychic and did everything my way,
everything would be fine.
Um,
and so I think that when I realized
that I couldn't fire someone, like,
I mean I literally would get a pit in my
stomach when I had to tell someone that
I, you know, didn't like the script
or didn't like their joke, I realized,
I was like,
I can't believe how hard it is for me to
feel like I'm disappointing someone or
just to tell the truth.
Quite frankly,
I had so I was so apologetic and
afraid of people not liking me. Sure.
That a,
it was really paralyzing and really a
unproductive and slow down the writing
process, uh, confused employees. I
remember in the room like, you know,
people would pitch jokes
and I would just say yes,
all of them because I didn't want to
hurt anyone's feelings and then I have to
go later and change it and
then all of a sudden the,
the script comes out and they're jokes
aren't there and they feel betrayed and
lied to. And you know, a, a phrase that
I love that when I first went to on,
I heard someone set up people
pleasing is a form of assholery,
which I just loved. Yeah. Because
you're not pleasing anybody.
You're just making them resentful because
you're being disingenuous and you're
also not giving them the dignity of their
own experience and assuming they can't
handle the truth.
It's so patronizing.
Yeah. It's a, it's a bandaid that hurts
a lot when it gets ripped off. Yeah.
And it just, there's a very short
book called lying by Sam Harris,
who's a phd in neuroscience,
has been on the podcast,
which digs into a lot of this
in a very interesting way.
Telec 30 leads a day or something.
Oh, I'm sure it's a three, 338.
Who does think it depends on the,
it depends on the person
or which politician you're
listening to you. But the, uh,
the point being like when you tell
white lies or you omit certain things,
they can ultimately have the same negative
impact as an outright kind of bold
faced lie to someone. Uh, so I,
I apologize for interrupting.
No, no, that's super,
I love that. The, I want to come
back to one thing you mentioned,
which is, uh, actually before I do that,
so was there a particular breaking
point where like I need to address this?
Yes. And again, I wish I had,
I wish I lied more actually.
I probably should lie.
And then your response to his question,
I um,
got pneumonia and I didn't notice
and it got really bad and uh,
turned into something called Costco.
Chondritis sounds bad,
which is does that you get it at Costco?
The good news.
It's really affordable and it's um,
basically the infection
from the pneumonia gets, uh,
in the muscles of your chest,
which is called pleurisy,
which people got like in like the civil
war. I mean it's like nobody gets this,
like you have to go so long without
polio.
It's like and a, and then it gets inflamed
the cartilage under your rib cage.
So it starts to just sort of,
your chest is really sore and essentially
I just wasn't taking care of myself
because I was so busy. I
mean, I was sleeping like
four hours a night and was in,
had to be in every meeting and every
editing session. And when I rewriting,
I was writing for scripts at a time
and I was just super over extended.
I had some family things happen.
My mom had a stroke at a family member
going to rehab and I just had no concept
of boundaries and you can't
give what you don't have.
I was the queen of giving everything
away. All my energy, all my time,
all my money, all my, you know, I was
like, I would cook a five course meal for,
but then I wouldn't eat dinner, you
know. Um, so I think, uh, you know,
I had this doctor say to me,
you know, he's like, you're
killing yourself. You know,
like you really like need to figure
out a way to be healthier because,
and that's when I kind of learned about
neurology and stress and cortisol and
adrenaline and F and F run
and, and how damaging they
can be on your body. And, um,
you know, I was like, I'm 27 and I
have three jobs. This is awesome,
but then it's all fun and games
until you know, until yeah,
you have leprosy till
your lungs. Yeah, exactly.
I just remember being like,
and I,
I think that to that point I
remember being at the doctor and,
and having this realization
because you know,
I grew up on Rosanne and mad about you
and three's company and like these like
multi cams and I love comedy. I
love Comedians, timer and be like,
I'm living my dream at 27
I have everything I wanted
for my whole life and I'm
not enjoying it. I'm at the doctor and
I have pneumonia and I'm like, you know,
managing people's Egos instead
of just like having a great time.
What's allowed you or what are the things,
and this comes back to something
you said about being very,
very good at some things and
very, very, very bad at others.
And I'd be curious to know what you
think the factors or beliefs or behaviors
were that allowed you to get
to that point at 27 I mean,
a lot of people will say, Holy
Shit, that's really young.
How would you get to that point from a
success standpoint and professionally?
Right? What were the things
that that contributed?
It got me to success.
I failed so many times and um,
wasn't deterred by it.
I for whatever reason,
saw failure as practice instead
of as the end the finish line,
you know,
if that makes any sense.
Like I wrote three pilots before
anyone even read a pilot I had written,
I um,
now pilot for those people who
are not sort of in the business.
That's is that a single episode on Spec,
single episode of like basically
the first episode of a TV show,
which is sort of has to introduce all
the characters and it's just a little
different than a traditional episode.
And I'm asked to be introduced
the world and be very specific.
So I wrote one about,
um,
the news in 2040 and it was like about
a new station and the news in 2040.
And it was kind of this apocalyptic take
on what the news was going to be like.
And the screen was like all covered an
ads and all of the news casters would
dress like NASCAR drivers with like
brands all over them. And you know,
they literally, every other sentence they
said, you know, they'd be like, you know,
so Costcos, you know,
Cincinnati is 72 degrees.
Like every state was sponsored by an ad.
It was just kind of a ridiculous, um,
sort of hyperbolic sort of, um,
thing and sort of about, you know,
there's a drought and there's no
water and it was like 180 degrees out,
which may end up not being far from the
tree. It might just be a documentary. Um,
so I, I, and everyone thought that was
kind of insane and no one really read it.
And then I wrote one that was,
uh, based on this book called, um,
uh, uh, it was about, uh, something
about, it was like a psychology book,
I think it was called, uh,
the, uh, I don't remember,
but it was about the 14 different
kinds of personalities, you know,
and uh, and I wrote about three
sisters that had the same mother,
but three different fathers.
And how those three different personality
types produce different sort of girls
and their relationship.
Foxton picked that up.
I wrote a pilot for comedy central,
uh,
which I still today till today I think
is the best thing I've ever written.
It was about, was based on
me and about, uh, just me,
uh,
falling in love with a guy who was in AA
and he can't date anyone outside of Aa.
So I pretend to be an alcoholic to get
in his life and I go to Aa and pretend
I'm getting sober to like get in his
life and then I fake a relapse and to get
his attention and the pilot and then have
to like drink and that actually become
an alcoholic. It's this really
ridiculous premise. And uh,
and they didn't pick that up,
but that's what Michael Patrick King
read that made him interested in me to
write two girls with him.
So everything that I,
and then I wrote a Spec for
a pilot that didn't even go,
that was Dane Cook's pilot or something.
So I was just constantly,
you know, IC. Yeah, IC comedy
and writing like med school.
It's like this is the only profession
where people think they should be famous
and be making millions
of dollars two years in.
It's like doctors go to med school
for 10 years, 12 years. Like, yeah,
it's not that different.
That's really interesting.
I had to Adam Gazzaley,
he's a neuroscientist at Ucla
on the podcast and he was like,
I was in school for 18
years. Yeah. Wow. Yeah.
Again, I've, comedians come up to me now
because with youtube and how fat famous,
everyone gets so fast or some visibility,
which I think is great.
They don't democratization
of comedy and entertainment,
but people like three years in,
or like I just,
I'm working on a Sitcom and I
don't have an agent. And I'm like,
you should in six years
we'll talk. Right. Get good.
And then we'll talk.
There's this entitlement now have,
I have 10 minutes of jokes and like,
where's my sitcom? Right. You know,
it's like, it's like a doctor going
to school for two years and be like,
I think I'm ready to operate. It's
like, no, Kelsey, in 10 years.
Yeah. Well there's a,
there's an expression in, um,
I think I'm getting this
right in Japanese, just
like he has the Samei Assay,
which is like gets hot ease that which
gets hot easily gets cold easily.
But I mean it's,
it's,
it's usually referred to people who find
a passion that they're really excited
about and they go all in and then
quickly drop it, which is kind of,
I guess my entire business
model, but the, the, uh, the,
I think that can be applied to so many
different industries and skillsets and
just a,
for instance,
I get asked all the time because I've
written a handful of books that have,
that have, uh, done decently well.
Uh, how do I hit the bestseller list?
And my point is,
you can game hitting the best seller list.
You cannot game staying on the
bestseller list and the ladder should,
the ladder should be your
focus. And they're like, well,
how should I market my book?
And I'm like,
it starts with writing a good book
because that is how you sort of perpetuate
and, uh, the popularity and get the word
of mouth. And I think it's, it's, I mean,
that's a sort of a content
one is to make the best seller list.
And I'm really care it wasn't that good.
Yeah. You know, cause that's
like the hypes and syndrome.
Yeah. And then it drops
off. And I think that, um,
if you haven't built that foundation,
it's very hard to have
any sustained success,
which is why certain
people like Justin Bieber,
very impressive that he came out
of that sort of a youtube. Yeah.
Farming's you know,
scouts scouting area and has been able
to sustain it as long as he has. I mean,
granted, I'm sure he's dealt with
his own, his own stuff, but, uh,
no one should be famous at 20. Can you
imagine if you were famous to 20? No.
The things you did when you were,
and by the way, my judgment,
my judgment was bad enough when you
were 20 with $50 million. Well, right.
It'll like take every bad decision
in pour gasoline on it had been,
had $50 million at 20. So many people
would be dead. The horrible things.
What about that? Uh, when
you do your best writing,
uh,
whether that's the pilot
that you mentioned that
involves AA or anything else,
when you do your best writing,
uh,
what does the process look like when you
look back at like the best stuff you've
done? Okay. What contributed
to that writing? It's awful.
It's awful. It's awful. Writing is
awful. Yeah, I agree with that. Yeah.
It's not sexy. It's not
glamorous. It's not easy.
It's, the more I've done it, the
harder it's gotten. Uh, you know,
because you don't want to become a parody
of yourself. You don't want to keep,
you know,
doing the same things.
You get sort of disgusted by
your own instincts. You know,
I've written that joke, I've written that
character or like, and then, you know,
it's gotten a little bit better cause
my inner monologue is a little bit nicer
to me these days. You
know, I worked on that.
I've worked on detaching from my negative,
uh, beating myself up. But writing is,
um, writings nasty, you
know, and you know, I've,
I've also gotten better as I've learned
about neurology in terms of like not
trying to multitask, not, you know, I,
my internet is cut off when I write.
I don't have my phone near me.
Um,
I don't try to edit and
write simultaneously.
You do sort of brainstorming or first
drafts on a computer or by hand?
I am really, um, very, uh, meticulous.
I'm, which I think a lot
of people have shame about.
A lot of people wanna be like, no, I
just like, I don't, I'm not like a,
I don't wing it. I write things out.
I'm very dorky. It's note cards. It's,
you know, 30 pages of a word
document of just all my thoughts.
And then I put my dialogue into at the
entire script goes into a word document
before I even open final draft.
So I'm pretty much done with it in a
word document with the dialogue because I
don't like to write in final draft because
it's just harder to go back and edit.
Okay.
Got It.
And because writing and editing or two
separate parts of the brain going back
and forth is just kind of paralyzes me.
[inaudible] I'm very easy to,
it's very easy for me to collapse.
So really I just,
I think the,
the most important thing is just
knowing your strengths and weaknesses.
So I know that it's hard for me to
stay focused if I'm looking at a, uh,
uh, um, a final draft document and
seeing the names of the characters.
I feel like all my God, I'm
screwing this up. This sucks inputs.
I like it to suck in word. So
the aesthetic of it is, oh,
this is just a rough thing.
It doesn't have to be good.
Yeah. Right, right, right,
right. It's a final draft.
I'm like, that's interesting.
The aesthetic. I'm like, oh,
did you feel like it should be better to,
exactly.
When I see the form of final draft,
it's like, oh my God, I suck. I said,
what am I doing in here? Right. So I've,
I've learned how to sort of like
quell my own fears and anxieties. Um,
it's a lot of pacing. It's a lot of
eating. It's a lot of going on walks.
It's a lot of, do you have a
set time or did you like when,
during these periods where you,
where you felt like you put out really
good work and that could be now obviously,
but, uh, morning, night,
middle of the night coffee one, like
what's the cocktail? The whole thing.
I do not drink pretty much.
Um,
when I'm writing I try not to
drink at all because I think, um,
since I've started eating so healthy,
my body just metabolizes out. I mean,
I used to,
I'm 32 now.
Something happened to me when I turned
30 where I just could not drink the way I
used to.
I on my 30th birthday,
someone sent me two shots of Tequila and
I'm pretty competitive, so he's like,
I bet you can't drink those faster
than me. And I was like, boom.
Okay.
So like the oldest trick in the book?
I did not. No, it's not that I
do that, but it's like, you know,
I, I can recognize it.
I'm like, Oh my God,
I bet you can take these two goofy's
fast timber roofing eating competition.
I just was like,
and I was like on an empty stomach and
literally I woke up in my bed the next
morning and I had like 30 minutes
calls and texts and people were like,
did you go home with John Mayer?
And I was like, you're like, I
hope so. I know. I'm kidding.
Did anyone get photos? I
don't even remember seeing
John Mayer. I was just like,
okay, I, I can never drink
tequila again. Certainly. Um,
but so I'm just like honoring
the fact that okay, I just,
I can't be as productive
and prolific when I drink,
so I don't drink when
I'm writing. I wait, wake
up. Um, I, uh, have like 30
minutes online. You know, I'd, I,
I really try to keep it to like four
basic sites. What are the, what are the,
I always do Huffington Post.
I do salon. I do slate,
one of Madison, Ashley Madison,
the Haka, Laura, Ashley,
Ashley Madison. Um, and then one
kings lane, which is like my sort of,
you know, um, thing.
And Dig sometimes and it kind of depends
what I'm working on because it's also,
if I'm writing right now,
I'm writing a pilot for HBO
that's sort of about gender and,
and it's got a lot of science in it. So
I'll go to psychology today. Jazz Bell,
the Frisky, which are kind of um,
the Friskies, the Friskies is like a,
it's like a website for girls that's
got a lot of like studies and this many
women admit to having orgasms and
masturbation is good for your health.
Sort of like edgy. It's like
cosmo. Some citations. Yes.
Smart cars,
smart guy.
And uh, so if there's anything
that's relevant or you know, and uh,
I'll look at Twitter,
you know,
I sort of follow all the major
news things on Twitter, but I,
once I get into that,
it activates a part of my brain that's
a little too self conscious and what's
everybody else doing?
So I tried to not do that cause I do know
that all of this is an addiction and I
have to sort of keep it under control.
I do coffee,
I do vitamins. How do you do
your coffee? I do my coffee. Um,
in a Keurig. Yeah, I do. Correct.
That's a hard one. Pure Ag. I know.
I couldn't say d. What was it? Decent
today. It's a lot of syllables.
That's that I need to do.
I need, I'm going to do,
I did any of that one out of the park.
Um,
I do a with almond milk and this
something all natural sugar.
I had this woman come in and take
all the carcinogens out of my house,
so I'm like making my own almond milk,
like an Amish slave these days.
It's really lives,
make amazing coffee.
Um, so, but I usually tie those beards
back. That's right. That's right.
And I try not to do too much
coffee and then I do on a smoothie.
Would you heard about,
but it's,
it's like kind of like
everything I need for the day,
so I'm not worrying later about
what I should eat for lunch.
Have I had enough time? Are you
waking up generally? Usually about,
depending on how late I'm doing shows
right now I'm touring to get ready for my
special.
So on the weekends when I am on the road,
I'll wake up more like 10 or 11
but when I'm writing, I try to,
I try to wake up early and when
I was writing a script last year,
I would wake up at like 5:00 AM and try
to work from like five to nine and go
back to sleep. Cause isn't that when our
brain is the most kind of for awhile?
Well yeah, it depends. I mean the of the
writers I know who are really prolific,
uh, and put out good work,
it seems like they all,
there are a couple of exceptions and I
hate them because I can't do what they do,
which is like, they're like, oh yeah, from
one to 2:00 PM I'll kick out an article.
No, can't do it. No. These writers,
the more common case I, they write
when other people are asleep. Yeah.
Whether that means staying up really,
really late, which I can't do.
Or waking up early really early yet. And
I was always the night owl version. Yeah.
But yeah, it's great to wake up at 5:00
AM cause you're not getting emails,
you're not on the mass emails
and whatever, you know.
So I would do that and then
go back to sleep. Got It.
Which was super helpful cause
my circadian rhythms are, um, I,
my nap game is pretty strong, I
believe. Very strongly enough.
Okay. So wait, let's, so let's
revisit that time period then. Okay.
So you wake up at five,
five, you do a four hour
blitz, like go back to
bed. When do you wake up?
I'll go back to bed at like noon or one.
A lot of times I'll sleep for like two
hours and then take another nap from like
seven to eight because then
I'll go to stand up at night.
So what I usually try to do
is break my day into two days,
like too many days because I mean,
I don't know how can be,
I think a lot of comedians
sleep really late.
But if I'm gonna wake up at eight and
then I have to perform at 10 right?
By the time it's 10 o'clock,
everyone else's winding down.
And then all of a sudden I have
to be like hilarious and charming.
So I'll usually take a nap at like six
to seven so that I wake up and like I'll
have a little bit of coffee and then
like go do stand up. Yeah, game on.
Very large, very Argentinian.
That's what they do kind of for the,
for the tango. I lived in Argentina for
nine months and the, in the tango world,
nothing really get started until 11
o'clock at night or, or midnight.
And so people would do exactly
what you're describing. Yeah,
the, okay. Got It. So then, uh,
during that four hour blitz,
you wake up,
are you still doing the 30 minutes
of Internet in the beginning?
I guess I don't, yeah, I'll do
it in the morning. Okay. To me,
that's always my eye because I know how
many interests we all have and how many
priorities we have. So it's, we
want to know what the news is.
We want to put nutrients in our body,
we want to connect with our parents
or loved ones or whatever it is.
So I'll try to get that all done as early
as possible so it's not looming over
me all day. So it's like if I've
just checked all the news, okay,
I know everything that I checked box,
I have my smoothie with all
my nutrients and it checkbox
can, you know, I know during the sound,
the sound check, which was spectacular,
but I made a solemn
promise not to use that.
So could you elaborate on this movie?
Okay. So I, um, uh, this woman, uh,
her name is Lori Cohen. Peter's,
uh, she's pretty amazing.
And she comes to Your House and tells
you everything in your house that's
killing you. Uh, basically your
cleaners, your food. I mean,
I thought I was like going to this
super all natural grocery store and she
literally,
I mean,
I had almond milk and Hummus
and raw and a mommy. I mean,
I think I'm nailing it right?
And literally, I'm like,
this one's going to come over
and I'm gonna get a refund.
She opens and she looks at me like,
like horrified. And she was like,
you're eating this. And I
was like, almond. She's like,
it's full of let the sin and level of law.
So cause I was also having some trouble
with 'em and my energy level and my
liver was a little and I wasn't
converting folic acid properly.
They were just like a couple
things that were up. And uh,
so she put the smoothie together
for me that it's uh, uh,
Kale of course that shovel of the
hour cause like guys do vegetable.
Um, I was in Savannah like two weeks
gone. Some was like, are you eating Kale?
And I was like, Kales officially made it.
It's in Savannah. People know about Kale.
It's fish, it's, it's officially in
the Zike guys. It's Kale, carrots,
Kiwi raspberries, avocado, olive oil,
flax oil,
some kind of green powder.
And then we put all my
sort of pills in there,
which is like a adrenal
support cod liver oil.
Yes. That's good. Uh, no
mercury, vitaminK , uh,
Alpha lipoic acid. Okay, thank you. Um,
desensitization, uh, uh, think,
oh co Q 10,
and I think that is maybe
that's playing 2% of the pelvis.
And then we actually make the shit.
And then we add the ingredient, right.
That's step one.
Uh, got it. And um,
okay. That all the old
released of like, okay,
I can kind of eat whatever I want all
day and I've gotten everything I needed
cause I could be, so I don't
know if this is the case for you.
If I need somebody to be done,
I can't stop thinking about it
until it's been accomplished.
So I just have to do it right away. I
can't be like, oh, eat a healthy dinner.
Cause then I'll just like worry about
it. That's on it. Have it on loop. Yeah.
So I know my limitations
and I try to just,
and so, so let's take,
uh, if you think, well,
let me ask a couple of kind of rapid fire
questions just for people who want to
get more familiar with your stuff.
So if you could recommend
that someone listen, listen, or
watch five minutes of your material,
of your stuff, five to 10, let's just
say, what would you point them to?
I would first tell you to
put your kids away. Yeah. Um,
I would point them to my last standup
special, uh, as you can see on my arm is,
it's called I love you as part
of the advertising campaign.
Um,
and I would,
I would just do the first five
minutes of my last special. Okay.
The first or the last first five
minutes of the last five minutes. Okay.
So if we, if we take a look
then at the first five minutes,
and I don't want to give away any secret
sauce necessarily, or the punchline,
literally, I guess, but,
uh, if, if we look at that,
where did it start?
Like what was the,
the kind of development process
of one of the five minutes? Yeah.
Or of like one of the bits, if
that's the right word. Yeah.
I don't know in those five minutes, like
where did it, where did it come from?
Them were, or, uh, I'd love to
just kind of track the, sure.
The growth and development of
that idea from pain. It came,
my stand up is, I'm always comes from, uh,
sublimating or alchemizing really painful
situations and to figuring out how to
make it funny. Okay. Uh, and so I went,
I was in a sort of really codependent,
unhealthy relationship.
I'm going to get an embarrassing question.
What does codependent mean?
Go to Bennett.
I was actually heard it used a
lot and I'd never been 100% clear.
That's actually a great, uh, question
because most people use it wrong.
Most people think codependence means
spending a lot of time with people or I
can't be alone or whatever,
which could be an element of,
but codepen dense is essentially that
you look to other people to decide how
you're feeling. So I go up, Tim's in a
bad mood. Uh, okay, now I'm in a bad mood.
It's like essentially you're a reactive
person and you put other people's needs
before your own. I got it. All
right. Thank you. That, so, you know,
I have a doctor's appointment.
Tim asked me to drive him to the airport.
I'm going to drive you to the airport
and I'm going to forego my doctor's
appointment. Your comfort
comes first, essentially.
And it usually codependence
breeds resentment, right?
So I'm going to do this for you.
And then two weeks later you're five
minutes late. And I'm like, well,
I drove you to the airport and you're
like, well, I didn't want you to,
you offered you martyr yourself,
essentially. Got It. Um, which is,
it's pretty nefarious because you're,
uh,
masquerading as really kind of Nice. So
everyone, when I was in the height of my,
my codependent glory days,
uh,
I was like the next person who would help
you move and I'd pay for the bill and
I was like the nicest person yet
people pleasing as far of assholery.
So then I was like annoyed at everybody
for not taking better care of me and
keeping score. And then, you know,
it's not a truly nice thing if you're
expecting something in return, you know?
So it's just a way to victimize
yourself and a way to, I'm like,
I don't know if you've ever dated someone
like this or had an employee like this
where some of that does nice things for
you and then gets mad at you for not
receiving the gifts the way they
wanted you to have them. Yes, yes.
Which is a way for your,
like you just started this fight
and made me a jerk. Do me a favor.
I didn't ask for it. Then the Lord it over
me. I just made you a four course meal.
It's like I didn't ask you to do any
of those things. Why are you, you know,
and then you get mad when they don't
appreciate it the way you'd want them to.
So codependence breeds resentment.
So,
but it's a tricky thing to catch and
recover from because again, your story is,
I'm just being nice. Um, so I was kind
of in a, in a relationship like that,
uh, with someone that sort of
recreated my childhood circumstances.
So it just felt familiar
and um, uh, I, yeah,
so that's the answer to that,
but I can't remember the material.
The bitten is five minutes
from your painful experience.
So I had all this rage after
I got out of it. Not Rage,
but just sort of like I was disrespected
in a relationship and I just took like,
you know, for I, I,
the reason I think I'm proud of that
first five minutes is because that was my
sort of more, I think getting your
heartbroken is really important.
If you're an artist, I encourage you
to get your heartbroken, get hurts,
fall on your face, make
mistakes, um, thaw the ice,
break through the defenses and get
vulnerable because I think that there's a
difference between getting your heart
heartbroken and getting your heart broken
open. And when it gets broken
open, you know, you can really,
that's where the meat is. That's where,
that's where you write great characters.
That's how you get vulnerable. And it's
important because I think Comedians,
we pride ourselves on how tough
we are. Yeah. But you know,
we're porcupines under there.
It's all marshmallow.
Just get to the marshmallow
cause that's where the gold is.
I promise if you just tell the truth
and get your heartbroken as a comedian,
you will have a house. That's cool. Yeah.
So I think you may mean a
lot of professions being
tough is what's valued in
comedy being weak.
It's like power through Vulnera
ability. The um, uh,
the speech that brings to mind for me
as a commencement speech by a writer I
really admire named Neal gay men love
them. Yeah. Make good art. Cat exploded,
make good on this happened,
make good art. And uh,
I think I'm quoting him correctly.
This is paraphrased of course. Yeah.
But I think I know that knew that you
liked him because on one of your podcasts
you brought him up.
Big Fan. Yeah. A little
bit of a fanboy, a yeah.
A bit of Ben is like understatement
of the podcast, but he, um,
amazing guys who have, I met him for
the first time, uh, in SF very briefly,
and I'd heard his audio books.
So it was extremely surreal to hear him
sound so erudite and extremely British
in person. And I was like, am I
listening to an audio book right now?
This is amazing. And uh, but the
line was something along the lines.
I'm saying lines a lot of, I'm
on, I'm on the home, on the line,
on the line theme, but he said, uh,
when you start to feel
extremely uncomfortable,
like you're walking down the street naked,
then maybe you're starting to get
it right. Oh, that's so great.
And when I put out,
I've experienced in my own writing where
I'll spend disgusting amount of time on
a given a blog posts,
let's say,
that I think is going to kill it and
they just flops or it was just crickets.
And then when I have that
extreme discomfort and, um,
I hesitate drafting it and
I hesitate publishing it.
Those are almost always the
pieces that do the best.
So even outside of comedy and
writing, I find that to be true. Um,
okay, so you have to take
this pain. Yeah. Did you,
did you take notes on the pain as you
were experiencing it or did you recall it
in one of your writing
sessions and put down the bone?
I remember actually,
and this might be cheating a little
bit and are not cheating, but, um,
I actually remember sharing and an Al
Anon meeting something that was really
hurt my feelings. And I was
like, and then he did this,
then he did this and people started
laughing and I was like, is this like,
and I realized, Oh my God, this is funny
because it's happened to other people.
People are relating and it's resonating.
And when you tell the truth about your
embarrassing moments and show your shadow
catharsis happens, which is what
laughter is, which is people go, me too.
You know? So it was
basically like, I was like,
the whole premise of that first five
minutes was what does love mean?
Because I feel like my whole
life love has been a very,
I think just in our culture in general,
love is a very confusing, vague,
manipulative word,
right? And, um, you know,
this is why I love working with animals
so much is that you only communicate
through behavior, not their words.
Because words can be so confusing.
Words mean something different
to everybody, you know?
And they have no bumps,
like can't get it. They have no, they
can't open your doors, steal your stuff.
That's true. That's true. They
can't read your blog and day.
This wasn't as good as the last
one. Right. Just love them.
They're your biggest fan.
Um, and uh, and so law of I,
I kept being in these difficult
relationships where it was always like,
but I love you but I love you.
And then it was like,
it would just undermine all of the bad
behavior and I feel like I was, you know,
the definition of insanity,
doing the same thing over and over again,
expecting a different
result. I was like, I keep,
I kept justifying being in
bad relationships because
of this vague amorphous
thing called love, which I was
like, so love means you hate you.
I love you means I hate you. Basic.
Like I just was. So I was like,
we need to all agree on
a universal definition.
I think that was my sort of
solution. I was like, we should,
because I see so many people getting
hurt and disappointed because their
definitions are different.
And then I sort of laid out what
I think my definition of love is.
And it should be very simple.
I'm not going to be happy and do the bit,
but it was like,
I was like,
my definition of love is being willing
to die for someone that you yourself want
to kill that. In my experience,
it's kind of the deal.
And uh, and if you love me, don't do
these 10 things that I had been through.
Like if I'm in the shower with you,
don't pee. It was like stuff like that.
Like is that so much to ask?
Like things like that. Like,
and I just listed all of my
grievances and I was like,
it's so great to be able to, um, you know,
that is what is great about comedy
is every time something bad happens,
I'm now conditioned to go like, oh,
this is gonna be a great joke. Yeah.
So every thing that sox ends up
being a gift somehow like, um,
when I first had money, like I grew
up without any money and I, uh,
got a car like seven years ago,
maybe it was,
I got my first car that I paid for myself.
It was a Lexus hybrid and
the first day I got it,
I filled it up with diesel fuel
and not the right thing to do.
Just destroyed it.
I mean it costs like six grand
or something. It was awful.
And I got this great joke
out of it though. I got like
a seven minute bit that,
you know, probably paid for
all the damage, you know, that.
So now I'm in this place where when
something bad happens I'm like, Oh God,
I can use that good material.
Exactly. So that organic, yeah.
Is the upside of being a comedian.
And um, oh, what was I going,
I was going to dig a little
bit further into that,
but maybe I can take a step back.
I was looking on Wikipedia,
which is, we all know he was always,
always a hundred percent factual, factual,
but it said genres, observational
comedy, blue comedy,
insult comedy. Oh. And I wasn't sure
what blue comedy was, quite frankly.
The other ones seemed a little more
straightforward. What is blue comedy?
Blue comedy? Um, I mean, I take, uh,
the fence to that. It's kind of,
it's not a lost thing. It's true.
I don't even know where it came to me
because I don't tell you blue comedies
thought it was like dirty cop,
edgy comedy, you know, and edgy.
Like Dan Carlin, Carlin, George
Carlin's up, a podcaster,
idolize. Oh, hardcore history.
George Carlin, George Carlin.
But it's tricky because it's like,
what is it again?
What is the definition of love?
What is the definition of dirty?
So for me it's like if you're talking
about an doing airplane jokes,
but using curse words,
is that dirty?
Or it's talking about sex
without Cursewords dirty kind
of, you know what I mean?
What's dirty to you?
And in our sort of puritanical society
where sex is still this really taboo,
uncomfortable saying. It's so interesting
to me cause it's like I do talk about,
I don't talk about sex.
Like I just talk about my personal
experiences and my confusion.
Cause to me sex is about power
dynamics and it's about masculinity and
femininity and um, and just
so many primal things. And it,
it fascinates me because I think we
think we have so much more choice than we
actually do in a lot of stuff.
And it causes the most of us,
the most amount of pain of any other
thing in our lives. Yeah. I mean you know,
being cheated on or being in love and
getting heartbroken. I mean this is like,
I mean every movie plot,
every where every,
all the money is spent on
Valentine's is all about this.
So to me it's like how can
anything be more relevant?
So the fact that I talk about
sex and someone calls it blue,
I'm like this is all anybody cares about.
Why is this still taboo?
Why Blue Blue? Oh good question.
Like in terms of why is blue,
cause why was usually the
symbol more for sadness?
Oh yeah. Blue comedy.
That's a good, I don't know.
I will look that up. That's an interesting
ediology goal. Ideological conundrum.
Ediology well, sure. The,
the, the words words,
uh, the study of
morphological. Oh, there we go.
Now you're pushing it. No, no. I
said obsequious let's not forget that
Asian studies major. So I can pull out the
linguistics word, the rules in a while.
A morphological. I haven't probably ever
used that in the spoken language before,
so, okay. That's blue. That's blue. Uh,
let's talk about insult comedies. So, uh,
you've done roasts before I in rows,
which, which roasts, what are some risks
that you've participated in Joan Rivers?
I did David Hasselhoff.
I did, uh, Donald Trump.
And now roasts are,
I mean,
just if those seem like treasure
troves of material. Well,
it's interesting because whenever
someone thinks that that is always a trap
because it's too obvious. Yes.
Too obvious. So Donald Trump,
everyone's gonna do hair jokes.
The first comment is going to do all the
hair joke. So by the time I go up six,
I have to have some other angle
that nobody's even have to think of.
Like the butterfly effect. Yes,
exactly. So we start with the hair,
but I went more for the, you
know, Russian mail order bride,
wife five to go to like a totally
different angle or, you know, you're
totally, I've got to go to this like
weird angle. And you know, John River is,
everyone's going to laugh at
the same thing. And, and um,
and David Hasselhoff is actually kind
of tricky because he's just more of a
general, he's just silly, you know,
like what, like what, you know,
so the angle on him was tricky to get,
but then there's a ton of other people on
the day as to, I did that in the early,
so I was a writer on the roast before I
was a performer on the roast. And, um,
you know,
I think it's tricky because I guess I
get defensive around that because maybe I
have some shame because I do feel
like they've gotten really mean.
And the way that roast, uh, originated
was actually the friars club roast,
which is a bunch of comedians roasting
other Comedians, Friar's Club in New York.
And it was all comedians roasting
other comedians. It wasn't comedians.
Roasting comedians are very
different than normal people there.
Their brain chemistry is different. Their
Migdal is different there. I mean it's,
I have a series of comedians should not
be let out in public. They're dangerous.
They're like armed and day.
They're just not safe. I mean,
it took me a silver tongue.
It just fell adjusted.
It just took me a long time to realize
you can't talk to regular well adjusted
people the same way you talk to comedians.
Cause we were like, hey asshole,
what's up? And we just make fun of each
other. And that sort of, it's not healthy,
but that's sort of how we show love to
each other is that we rip each other and
make fun of each other. And,
uh, you know, and it's, it's,
it's funny because actually you'll know
this is that, you know, Brian Callan,
which is how I know you own,
which you met him on,
what was it through apple Tinder,
we first connected. It was, it was, it
was very funny. First we met on Grindr,
most of his photos did
not involve his face.
And then we met again on Thrinder,
which is Tinder for threesomes.
And finally we were like,
you know, not that attracted to each
other, but we share a lot in common.
It's just books and drink some coffee,
be friends. I actually don't know.
I don't recall how I first met Brian. I,
yeah, this is like common issue for me.
Just sort of creeps into your life
in a very insidious way. Yeah.
He's like a bill due or like an
STD shows up. You don't know why.
And you just spend the rest of your
life trying to get rid of him. Um,
so I remember him, you know, he,
and, uh, Brendan have a podcast yet,
which I think you've done right.
And I remember going on the podcast
and Collin and I, I was just,
we were trashing each other. I
mean, it was like bad. I mean,
and then Brendan,
who's not a comedian and I'm trashing
him and I know when he's like,
are you guys fight it? I mean,
like it does look like a lawful,
and then I'm sort of treating
Brendan the same way.
And Brendan was like so insulted and upset
and it was just, I was like, oh my God.
Like, sorry. It's a completely
different language. So the roasts,
again initiated with Comedians,
roasting Comedians,
and then when it got on comedy central,
all of a sudden they start bringing
in like Pamela Anderson and you know,
just these perfectly nice people with
feelings who aren't numb to the core and
you aren't sociopaths. Right? And
so when you start mixing that,
that's when it started getting,
you start seeing people
getting their feelings hurt
and you know, and also again,
Comedians,
I actually are more sensitive than anyone.
So when you start having people who aren't
comedians making fun of us, it's like,
oh no, you haven't earned the right to
call me up. You don't have your straps.
Jeff Ross can call me a whore,
call me more. It's like all of a sudden
we have these boundaries. Well, that's,
well, that's funny you mentioned
that because it's like, I am. Okay.
There was this piece in the New York
Times, which was a, uh, sort of a,
it wasn't a takedown piece because it was
too funny. It was like a parody piece,
uh, related to the four hour body. And the
guy was like, it's like the New England,
uh,
what would he say?
It was like the New England Journal
of health or something like that.
I was hijacked by the skymall
catalog or whatever, and he was like,
actually very funny stuff.
Didn't bother me at all.
But then there's someone
who tries to be funny,
but it's not a good writer who
slams me. And I'm like, no, no, no.
If you're Gunna do it, yeah. If
you're gonna do it, do it. Well,
I always say, uh, in order
for a roast joke to work,
it has to be funnier than it is mean. Ah.
So if it's not funnier than it is mean,
it's always going to bomb. So it's like
you're walking this tightrope of like,
if you're going to make it a joke,
at better be an a plus joke.
If you make a c h joke, you get
a boo. If you make an April,
which is sort of what I like. Excuse
me, I'm being attacked by bugs. Um,
something that I loved about the
roast is sort of the math of it.
Cause those jokes are all math jokes.
You know what I think about the adding
and subtracting a word can completely
change the response there. They basically
tight Catskills jokes. For example,
one of my favorite jokes,
I'm cause I won't say my own jokes,
cause that would be
narcissistic and give me shame.
So I'll say one of my favorite, uh, Rose
Comedians, Jeff the ledge, Greg Geraldo,
he had a joke for ice tea once.
He said ice tea. You're so old.
You used your first residual
check to buy your freedom,
which is just a brilliant joke.
Um, but it's all math, you know,
it's just set up turn, you know. Those
were the kind of jokes that, uh, you know,
we do with the roasts
where it's like a few,
any other word combination would
not be as funny. Yeah. You know,
you change one word. Um,
I remember, uh, some more,
I wrote this joke that was, it's a
horrible, really dark joke, but, um,
I said, uh, it was a flavor flavor host.
I was right around that. And it was,
the joke was flave you look like what
Magic Johnson should look like. Right.
So I wrote that joke and she
delivered it in a way that it moms,
she was like, you look like how Magic
Johnson should be looking right now.
And it's just too many words. So I, yes,
I love the economy of words.
You can take two words out
and use a different screen
laughing and pause. Break.
Yeah. So that kind of stuff is still feel
like Twitter is good training for that.
Interesting. Yeah. I've,
I've been astonished when I tried to
draft something and I'm like, God damn it,
you know, negative 23, oh, how
do I get what I want to keep it,
I want to keep it and then I trim it down
and I'm like, it's so much better. Yeah.
Concision is Yep.
100%.
So I love that is sort of something I
loved about the roast ultimately. Um,
you know,
I think that rose,
so I think it's important to know when
to to stop doing something. You know,
one of my favorite Steve jobs things is
what I don't make is just as important
as what I do make sure,
right?
Like what you say no to is just as has
just as big of an impact on your career.
So I did three of them and it
felt like, you know, that was,
I was getting known as the roast girl
and I was getting known as this insult
mean insult comic.
And I'm not like that at all.
I'm like the super fragile sort of scare
Burson and I would have by being an
airport and someone be like,
Hey Kotton I'd be like Whoa,
it's two o'clock on a Tuesday.
Like if people just thought they could
talk to me like that and it would really
freak me out. It's crazy.
People would say that.
Words like that to me on the
street, it's so wild. I mean it's,
it's very unusual dynamic.
Obviously when you're public facing
and people feel like they know you
intimately and in some cases they,
they might right.
If they've read all your stuff,
washed all your stuff,
they actually probably know quite a lot
about you but you can have that type of
experience or like I'll have guys come
up to me in the like I'll be taking a
piss at a urinal and some guy like come
up and like give you a slap on the back
and start like kind of breathing into my,
you're talking to me as if he's
like my buddy from high school.
Never. Yeah. Speaking with
there. I did. Granted,
I did respond to that for a good time
call and the inside of the bathroom I was
in an airport, you know, surprise
me, especially in the airport.
I'm thinking security,
the guy must work here.
Isn't that a violation of some
kind of TSA regulation? But uh,
it is very interesting
because I think, uh, you know,
when it's so rewarding to be able to
share the intimate details of your life
with people and help people laugh at it
or in your case, help them, you know,
with their confidence or their
business or their goals or whatever.
But people laugh at me
and then to sort of compromise
this level of privacy. It's,
it's usually okay for me,
but I just don't have very thick skin.
And I have this theory that
the third thing someone says,
a stranger says to you is always
an insult. Hey, such a big fan.
Love your work.
You're so much bigger
in person. Cause the third one
is always there. Honest answer.
The first two is just their adulation.
So I always try to just get out after
the second compliment. That's really,
that's really funny. Yeah.
I was listening to, uh,
I'm an avid consumer of, of stand up.
Definitely afraid of ever doing it.
That's a, that's something maybe
talking about, but uh, I think it was,
I was other Demitri Martin or Mitch
Hedberg love I think when they're saying,
you know,
when like when I take photos I like to
count to five because that's when people
get real play one here.
It's coming to the last tier
three smile for what? Five,
what the fuck. And then
I take the photo. So fun.
I'd like to meet Jay.
Demetrius linear. Yes.
Great. He has a lot of great
photo jokes. He was, he's like,
I love a camera phones cause
you can reminisce immediately.
We were so young. He has his, a lot of
good word play jokes too. So it's like
delightful,
playful joke.
Yeah. Like the silent, the silent G. Yeah.
We use that screw up foreigners like in
foreigner. I'm right there, you know. So
hello. It's such a, um, you know, there's
a lot of different kinds of comedy.
I had a sort of argument about
this with someone recently.
It was a kind of notion would
come you so negative, you know,
and it was like there's a lots of
different kinds of comedy is just like,
there's lots of different kinds of music
and art and whatever. Um, but you know,
Dimitri and, and um,
Zach Galifianakis and uh,
Mitch Hedberg and Steven Wright are
in this sort of Ashkelon of certain,
this playful tickling sort of
stuff. I mean, like Dimitri,
one of my favorite jokes of
his, his, he's like, you know,
it's like people always want to show
me photos of their kids and then I show
them photos of their kids and
think I'm weird. I mean it's just
little stuff like that that's sort of
fantastical, surreal comedy
should the economy to it. I mean,
which I really like also. It's like
precise Haiku comedy. Yeah. It's very fun.
It's repeatable. There's something
democratic about it cause you can,
you can't rehearse,
say one of my beds to someone that's long
and convoluted and requires too much.
It requires too much narrative
practice. It's physical. You know,
there's also a guy named Dan [inaudible]
who tells the kind of jokes that you
can easily suppose. Man's m. I. N. T, z.
He wrote for Louis C K show on
HBO. Uh, he's doing something now,
but, um, he has a great show. Kiko
is a, it's a little bit, you know,
blue, but he goes, um, he goes, you know,
it'd be really confusing if someone was
performing an abortion and someone ran
in and yelled,
abort a horse.
Oh God, that is blue. It's very fun.
It's obviously a joke, you know,
but it's just one of those is you hear
it once and you can repeat it a parties
forever, you know, it's
like the one, I'm not,
not to make this the Dmitri Martin's
show, but yeah. Uh, the, uh,
the one, uh, I think this is
all on the same album too,
and I'm blanking on the name of the album,
but he says, he says like, you know,
it's along the lines of, you know, like
what does it, what does a Dalmatian
think when he sees a cow? You're like,
am I hiring? And then the
cows, like he looks amazing.
I like to tell the ground over here.
You know,
it was like a part of your brain that's
never activate like things where you're
like, I've never thought about
that. But I mean think about it.
People like us and anyone who's listening
to this is probably an overthinker,
but we've thought of everything, you know,
we've overthought everything 50 times.
And so when someone puts of the visual
in your mind that you've literally never
entertained, it's just so like, it's
like being a kid again or something.
That's what I feel watching it.
Mitri uh, the um, the
roast. Yes. Thinking Bruce,
part of what makes them so
different now aside from the fact
that you have non comedians being like
harpooned by 20 professionals is a,
that it's preserved.
So instead of being in a
club with an expiration date,
that was the end of the day. It's
on youtube, comedy central forever.
Good plant and a very different
sort of persistence. Yeah. Yeah.
Well also I see the roasts
as more of a sport. Like,
it's like watching boxing or football or
something where you're watching someone,
you know, get schooled and someone comes
back and bites him back and you know,
it's, I think that activates that very
primal part of your brain of kick his ass.
Yeah. You know, and I think I, you
know, it started getting so nasty and,
and I think the roasts were better.
They're better when you're the underdog,
you know? And people like to see a
Rudy come on, you know? So I for it,
but in my first roast and it was like,
who's this girl? And then I, you know,
came out of the gate and
like knew what I was doing.
And then when I started to sort of,
it was like my,
I had an acumen for it and people start
to expect all of a sudden when people
expect you to be good, I think we're
down. So then they think either you suck,
you're like, wait a minute, you thought
it was great when you never heard of me,
now you've heard of me, and now you want,
you know, everyone wants to build you up.
So they can just tear you down. Yeah.
And then I felt like, okay, right.
It's good to know when to go out and,
um,
and I'm sure she'd be fine with me
sharing this, but then the last,
the Donald Trump rose, Lisa Lampanelli
and I, we just cried after the roast.
We were like, it was just two below
the belt. It was like, yeah. You know,
the Goto for me and I, again, I've
been in the writer's room of the roast.
I know the math of it.
I know that it's like we're going
to make fun of what you look like.
I try to not make fun of things about
people that they can't control as a
general rule. Yeah. Cause it
just feels a little too mean. Um,
with the exception of some jokes I
wrote about carrot top, but come on. Um,
uh, but I regret those and
then I feel bad about them. Um,
and that one was just a
little below the belt.
It was like people were calling me a slut.
Like I was in a relationship at the time.
It was just like, what are you doing?
Like this didn't cause an argument.
Like it was just,
it's so salacious and incendiary
that I felt like I, it was,
I was so,
it just hurt my feelings after awhile.
And Lisa Lampanelli and I were both like,
she had just lost all this weight and
they used to make fun of how, you know,
that she was overweight and she had lost
weight and now they're making five skin.
It was just like, oh, you can't win. It's
whack them all. Yeah. You know? So, uh,
we were like, I think it's probably
good to switch. Take a break. Yes.
Switch sports.
What, um, what would you do if you had,
say this is all hypothetical,
obviously eight weeks you take someone
who's never done standup but has spent a
little bit of time on the stage. Yeah.
Let's call that person a friend of mine.
I, he just wondering for myself, uh,
eight weeks to get them ready to do five
minutes on stage at like an open mic.
Right. Uh, what would you do?
Uh, that's a great question. I would
get them on stage the first night,
the first night. Yep. First Day of
eight weeks. Yep. Okay. And this entire,
every night for all of the eight weeks,
whether they had material or not,
because the material is like 10%
of it being comfortable on stage.
It's all of it, you know. So I
would say just get on stages.
I say always say the
first year and a half,
two years of standup is just
getting comfortable on stage here.
Material doesn't matter.
Like it's like, um, uh,
boxing or whatever, you know. Um, but, uh,
I would just say get on stage
as much as possible and um,
because your material and the for the
first couple of years is never going to,
no one's ever going to see it, you know,
it's just an excuse to get up there. Um,
and I would also ascertain where they
are in terms of their self awareness and
PR and opinion. Like I would ask them
50 questions about where they're from,
what makes them different.
Because I think a lot of people have
this dysmorphic view about what's
interesting about them. So I have
this girlfriend, she's a comedian. Uh,
and what was the thing? Oh, uh,
she goes on stage and she was talking
about like smoking pot and hooking up with
guys and you know,
she's sort of a younger comedian and it
was just sort of everyone kind of does
that.
And then later I found out that she was
a competitive diver in college and I was
like, why don't you talk about that? I
have in your mind to that. And she's like,
oh no, I mean it just seems boring.
I'm like, no one else has that.
Like I'll do it if you don't do
it, I'm stealing it. You know,
like a lot of people,
a lot of times people don't know
what's interesting about them.
So it takes a while. Cause
I think we all, you know,
are so sick of ourselves in some ways
are we inflate things and deflate other
things and have denial about things.
Um,
so tap into what's makes you,
you and why.
What's interesting about you
also help you figure out,
it took me a long time to realize
that as soon as you get on stage,
you need to address what the
audience is already thinking.
I was just going to ask
if you like if you grabbed the gun
and shoot yourself with it before.
Yup. Yup. So they, uh, I don't
know who says this quote that um,
comedians become comedians so they
can control why people laugh at them.
Just so interesting. So for me, I really,
I wish I could do that. I need this skill.
I realized right away that people thought
my last name being Cummings was funny.
Yeah.
And I didn't never understood.
So I get onstage and I started
talking and then I'd be like, oh,
my last name is comics.
Everyone start laughing.
Like she just put the
needle in the balloon. Now
I can move on. You know,
your tweets. What was it?
I wouldn't let any husband take my last
name unless it's first name is Dick
thought that was pretty good. Always
held out as husband took her last name.
I think. I was like, thinking about it.
Um, you know, cause I always say like,
people are like, do you
wanna get married? I'm like,
I just want to change my last name.
You don't have to marry me,
but can I just take your last name?
We don't have to sign anything and my
last name be verus bleed. Um, but I have,
I am grateful to that last name because
I think at a very young age I had to
learn to defend myself against ridicule.
So I, you know, had to get quick.
Witted um,
so how would you do an
inventory for someone to figure
out what those things are
about them?
Yeah,
so you can like slay the pink
elephants before they have a chance to,
like I would ask,
right. I would, um, you know,
I'm very, uh, very direct person.
Like I remember seeing a, you
know, there's a lot of like, um,
I don't know what is the social and
the politically correct thing to say.
Is it little people now?
Is it not endorsed?
I don't know what the proper
term is. A little people. Okay.
I think midgets,
not the m word is the new n word.
And we're definitely not, and not the
Amara calling her calling food oriented.
I, it's a little people.
So a friend of mine,
it's a little person and
he's a comedian and uh,
he goes on stage and he's just like, so I
was with this girl then I was like, you,
your first 10 minutes is talking about
being a little barbs barbicide now how do
you prevent that from being much like
going after Donald Trump for the hair,
right? Two obvious. Like they expect
you to do that. Well, first you have to,
I mean it's, you know, a lot of
people say standup is like sex,
but like you have to be in
it's really malicious and very,
really malicious and violence
and like 10 minutes long. Um, uh,
basically you have to admit it to,
what am I staying?
Secret to happiness is low expectations.
Please four hour work week,
the four minutes,
um,
and, but you have to understand what
their needs are and be able to feed and
ascertain.
Like I say,
so much of comedy is just
listening and it's a conversation.
It seems like a monologue ostensibly,
but it's actually a conversation so
you're constantly checking in with them.
I always tell a lot of comedians who in
the beginning aren't doing well and I'm
like, well, are you making eye
contact with the people in the crowd?
And there was like, no. I'm like, oh, it's
so intimate. Like you have to, I mean,
I literally look all of them
in the eyes all the time. It's,
you're constantly checking in, constantly
checking in. The sound is one thing,
but you also have to be checking in with
them and knowing what they need from
you, you know? And so for me,
the first couple years I had
to address the last name,
Cummings in the beginning
everyone was like, cool,
we don't have to think about this
anymore because other people did too.
They just hit Cummings is her last name,
comma, and then they're distracted.
So you just have to take it off the
table or we, can we move on here? Okay.
My last name is Cummings. Now let's
get to some other stuff. I've always,
it's one of these things where
you think it's going to get old.
I'll you what it is,
it's
Jim Gaffigan's voice that he
does to imitate the crowd. Yeah,
exactly. It's so empowering. That's
freedom. Yeah. And just the, yeah,
I just thought it was
such a, it's such a, uh,
such a clean,
that kind of elegant way
the audience in on nail it. Yes. You know?
Yeah. It's so great because it, it just,
it takes the elephant, like you said,
out of the living room. You know,
another thing I did recently and just
when I kind of thought, okay, enough,
people know me, I don't have to. Um, so I,
this is such a weird thing to say. Uh,
I like get like, I mean I put a lot of,
I take good care of my skin.
I try at least.
But one of the crowd questions was,
how is your,
how do you get your skin so glowing?
So maybe, so maybe you could explain,
talk about that. Um, but,
but sometimes on stage it I look
really shiny and I look all the time,
we know that this is what you're,
I mean I can't totally,
but you look just like your
my face cause you look good.
You're just like an orb of light.
Yeah but the same as me so I get really
shiny and then one time I was on stage
and I was like do I look really shiny?
And everyone just burst out laughing
because it was like the elephant in the
living room. I'm like why is
she wet coming from a storm?
And I was like Oh my God you guys,
I'm not wearing any makeup.
And I put like cream like oil on before
I came onstage number was like oh like
it was like now we can talk about that.
We can move on right now.
I can pay attention to what you're saying.
Totally.
So it's like just sort of being able
to have that kind of self awareness,
which is,
it's hard because it's like you want
self awareness but you don't want self
absorption. You want to be able to
self reflect would not be a narcissist.
You have to, you know, it's,
it's, it's a delicate balance.
I think I would also work,
who are some comedians who come to
mind like right off the bat, I'm sure,
I mean there are a lot of
really good comedians out
there, but just like offhand,
people who are good at walking
that tightrope between self aware
and self absorbed. Ooh,
good. Um, good, good,
good, great question.
David. Tell, Oh yeah,
David Tell I couldn't have
more love for David towl. No,
kind of, I feel like he's
not, he doesn't penetrate,
I mean too much emotionally. Like I
feel like Dave's not super vulnerable,
at least onstage, offstage. He is. Um,
but I would say like is a great Greg Bill
Burr Bill Burr Wilbur is a monster and
he has this great ability
to, I mean he's, you know,
on stage is somewhat obsessive
and neurotic and you know,
he's got podcasts and he, you know,
um, gets really obsessed with things,
but he's able to move on real quickly
and not make it about him. It's,
he's not myopic, you know, he's a
really good at responding
to the crowd too.
And he'll say something and he's
really, really good and he'll go, Ooh,
I lose Ya. You were with me and
now I feel like you're pulling it
when he does that because even
in it, and it's such a, you know,
maybe this will interest your fans that,
that he is one of my favorite comedians
to watch because he will almost ordain a
bombing so that he can,
because he's so successful now and I've
seen him be on stage and just be killing
and he's like, that wasn't that
funny. You're laughing cause he wants,
he'll like premeditated.
He,
he'll sort of like Holby like black
people are different and people go ooh.
And he'll be like,
just let me,
so he'll throw at something so incendiary
that he loses the crowd like on
purpose just so we can get them back.
Which is so cool because it's like what
do you do when you're that skilled is
you have to keep it so you don't plateau.
You have to keep creating Roy Jones jr
at his peak when he would just like drop
his arms and do these like rooster
fighting posture is cause he's like,
how do I make this interesting for myself?
100%. That's exactly it. You know, I,
it doesn't Laird Hamilton, uh,
uh, swim with a cement block.
He does exercise, uh, in
pools underwater with weights.
Yeah. Something like Riddick
where you're just like, oh,
you're just bored at this
point. Um, so I'll see him,
he'll throw something out
where he'll be like, you know,
maybe the Holocaust was good for us. And
then everyone's like, Ooh. And he's like,
well, and then he gets
a Mac. Right. You know,
and it's like he'll throw something out
that you think is like the point of no
return. You think like his
career is over and, uh,
and then he gets a Mac, you know, so he's
so cool, but he's not like, you know,
a narcissist. He's not stuck in his
own. I think one of the biggest dangers,
you know,
as a comedian,
and I always worry about comedians who
aren't friends with other comedians
because we're who we check each other
and keep each other sort of sane is when
comedians get to sequestered they,
or any big personality or someone with
opinions who ends up being surrounded by
staff and the Jim Carey's of the world
who gets sequestered and all of a sudden
they have no point of reference with
reality and that kind of lose touch. Um,
you know,
so bill is also great about,
he's in the trenches is the comedy store
every night. He's talking to people.
I mean, he's, that's part of the reason I
think is, you know, comedy song decisive.
Who are some of the most underrated
comedians? Great question.
Um, uh, great question. Sebastian.
Maniscalco that's a hell of a name.
It's a hell of a name a,
I'll send you his stuff.
He's, um, he's just
n I.
S C a.
L c o Sebastian is,
uh,
I encourage any creative people to
watch him because he is all Calco.
He, uh, has some Italian, uh,
blood and he's almost like a Brian
Regan or like a more flamboyant Jerry
Seinfeld. He's completely
clean. And I, this isn't,
he's one of my favorite comedians. So I
hope this doesn't come off pejorative,
but he almost doesn't have jokes per se.
Like if you were to transcribe his
act, you wouldn't see jokes. Huh?
It's so much in his performance and
essentially his sort of thing is just
discussed with humanity,
like whole,
and I'm not going to embarrass myself by
doing his act, but he'll just say like,
uh, he'd be like, so, uh, anybody
have the, uh, the Blue Ray? Like,
and he'll just like say facts
about the blue it right. His just,
his point of view is so specific and
authentic and he's so genuinely angry that
it's just hilarious. So it's like whatever
you are, be that if you're annoying,
be that if you're a republican,
it'd be like, whatever it is,
exaggerate what you already is.
As long as you're pretending to be someone
you're not, and the audience knows.
So stand up is the ultimate exercise
and accepting exactly who you are,
as ugly as it is,
as long as you tell the truth they're in,
because they can tell,
most people can tell when you're,
which is why equine therapy is
actually been really helpful for me.
So talk to me more about the
horses. What's, what's going on. So,
so the metastatic
oh yeah, it's smashing. It's got to go.
If, if any comedy nerds want to know more,
um, underrated people, uh,
Sebastian Maniscalco is great. Um,
Gerard Carmichael is great.
I think he's probably, um,
you're going to be hearing
his name a lot more soon.
Natasha Ligero is very funny. Tig Notaro
I'm sure you guys all know her by now.
Um, crystal Leah, I'm a fan. Uh,
you probably already know him. Um,
Brian Callan is actually overrated.
I would say.
Um,
this is where retractable
claws to eviscerate our friend.
And you're like, I know. He's our friends.
That's why I'm going to humiliate him.
I'm Neal Brennan cocreated, the
Chappelle show with Dave Chappelle had,
has now started doing stand
up and it's super, um,
incisive and funny,
uh,
commentary on race and gender that very
few white people can get away with.
Yes. That's hard to get away. He's
very hard to get away with a win.
Especially if you look like
me. American history. Yeah.
You're kind of asking for very
unfavorable media covering American.
Go buy it. Well, you know,
I'll take it that it must be because
my skin is so luscious and well, yeah,
I mean between your skin and my skin. I
mean we are, we need to turn the AC on.
I want to,
so I will come back to the equine therapy,
but before we get there, I want to come
back to the eight week training program.
Right. So for your friend? For
my friend Jim, Sarah's, uh,
I,
because for instance,
and I think I'm probably not the
only person with this insecurity,
but I don't feel like a
very funny person and,
and I worry about,
so for instance,
there are certain circumstances that
literally like maybe three where I'm like,
someday if I ever do stand up,
this could be funny.
But there are so few of them that I'm
like, wow, I would be, I would just get,
I'd be roadkill.
We tried to go up for five minutes and
actually one of them earlier before we
started recording, you came out of the
bathroom and you're like, I just want to,
I did not create the mess in there. Uh,
and so, you know, my thing has been like,
what do you do when you like walk into
the bathroom and some like bashful person
comes out and the next scurries away
and then you walk in, you're like,
this is a fucking disaster.
But like,
I'm in an airplane and somebody is
behind me. I fucking clean it up.
Or do I leave it? Like, I'm not
going to have a conversation
after it. Right, right.
But I only have like two or three of
those over several decades of being on the
planet. Right. How do you come
up with, here's the good news.
Yeah. She'll love is it's a muscle. Okay.
So the more you work at
the stronger I guess,
and then you'll be like me and you'll
be haunted by everything you look at.
All you can think of is how
to make it a joke. You know,
it starts being more and more and then
you're up at night and like you're having
sex with someone and you're like, oh, this
would be a good joke. And you're like,
oh my God, can I just get
a second? Anatomies yeah.
So it starts becoming like pretty
relentless. But yeah, it's a muscle.
Like any muscle, you know, the first
couple of weeks you go to the gym,
you're going to be a little sore.
So what is the, if it's the
muscle, if it's a muscle,
what is the workout look like?
What are potential exercise
to potential exercises is, um, you know,
I remember like when I first started,
I would like go around my
house and be like, Trashcan,
what's funny about a trash
can? Like what's I think
the best way to do it is to,
which is also helps to, um,
what's the word? Uh, uh,
when you, um, when you, I'm making weird
yeah. Model you're making,
you're making hand gestures.
It looks like a squid
called debate.
When you cultivate your voice,
figure out what interests you.
So what I would first do is figure
out what pisses you off so people's
limitations piss you off the airport.
Bathrooms piss you off.
What pisses you off?
Because I always say comedy is for
the most part just an obsession with
injustice. So most comedians have a
very deep obsession with injustice.
This isn't fair. And that's what
we get on stage and talk eight,
unless you're Demitri Martin and Mitch
Hedberg and you're sort of doing those
sort of one liner, a sort of
more playful, surreal jokes.
Um, so what pisses you off?
And you know, Louis Ck says,
if you think about something
more than three times a week,
you have to write about it. What's, yeah,
what's haunting you? What's plaguing you?
What's pissing you off?
What do you spend most of your
time thinking about anyway? So,
um,
you know,
you can't stand your ex boyfriend and
you are ex girlfriend and she's posting
photos on Facebook and
anything that pisses you off
just cause I was on grinder grind, me
and I have a boyfriend. Let's be clear.
There you go. Whatever. I
know you're not monogamous.
That's what they say on the message
boards. Schreiner um, I did some research,
so it's actually,
whereas
most, and it's interesting, I
remember it, you or listen to a,
one of your podcasts episodes where you
were talking about negative thinking.
There's positive thinking,
but then the uh,
I'm going to botch it and
plagiarize it horribly.
But the power of negative
thinking to prevent or something,
it's almost like common pursing the
worst case scenarios to avoid them,
which is so cool to me.
So I always say that comedy is like a
very delicate combination of positive
thinking and incredibly negative
thinking because you know,
you take the toilet thing and then you
times that times a million and you go to
it's worst extreme of what's the worst
possible thing that could happen,
the catastrophe. And then you
make it a joke. So I, you know,
you mentioned Louis C K I feel like he
has gotten a lot better at infusing the
positive. Uh, and I, again, I'm not,
this is just going from some of, uh, some
of his albums, which are still very fun.
But then getting on say a late
night show and talking about like,
everything's awesome and nobody, nobody's
happening the Wifi on the airplanes.
Yeah. Well he's also, I mean,
it's interesting because comedians are
also human beings who grow and change. So,
you know, a lot of people say you
about Howard Stern in the 90s.
He was much angrier because he was in
a bad marriage and now he's in a great
marriage and he's much happier,
you know, so it's also, you know,
I think you have to be very flexible
in your standup. So my first hour,
I mean I was 26 or something, so I
wasn't even a person yet. But, uh,
I was very like, I thought it was
right about everything. And you know,
in your twenties you think you
know everything and you know,
I was like loud and you know,
um,
and then my second special I had sort of
life had kicked my ass a little bit and
I was more humble and I was more
like, I don't know anything, you know,
my neck specialists sort of in and even
more so all of my specials are just,
so it's a different person in each
one, you know. So, um, you know,
Louis C K I think now that he's gotten
so successful and so exalted in lauded,
it's like he's almost like, you know,
just a different guy who was 10 years ago.
Yeah. He has less anger and he's able
to come from a different perspective.
So I also think it's important to not
become a parody of yourself and to be able
to be flexible. Yeah. Yeah. Well that's
why when people ask me, for instance, uh,
how would you edit your
first book? [inaudible] uh,
if you went back to edit it.
Yeah.
This has come up because the
10th anniversary is coming
up in about two years.
And my answer is almost always,
I wouldn't edit much because I wrote it
when I was 29 and I was in a different
place in my perspectives
have shifted. Yeah. Yeah.
But that book strikes a chord with a lot
of people who are facing similar thanks
to, I tried to rewrite it now I don't
have the kind of boots on the ground
experience with those issues right
now to the extent that I did then.
And I would fuck it up.
Right, right, right, right.
I would rob it of that kind of immediate
relevance. Um, that's interesting. What,
uh,
what would you do night of? So
eight weeks past? Yep. Okay.
All right. Got a crowd, not just your mom,
not just your friend or the novice.
This is for the novice you've taken
from ground zero over eight weeks.
But just so you know, over the eight
weeks, I'm having them go up every night,
whether they're bombing or not. Three
spots a night, at least three spots
on stage. Three times you're
driving to three different things.
Three different clubs. You're
driving to a club, to a coffee house,
to a bowling alley.
When I first started for the first
three years was doing bowling alleys,
parking lots, uh, Sushi restaurants,
just ambush a,
what is that with these Audis?
Probably easier to get it for you to get
away with the drunk guys lie. Oh Hey,
I shanked a couple times they got
amazed. Um, but no, in La, I mean,
and this was the time of my space.
So it was a time when there was all these,
you know,
shows at restaurants and bowling alleys
and laundromats and people would just do
these sorts of shows everywhere.
And I would say, can I get on?
And you just had to constantly hustle and
you're my spacing all day to get spots
and then driving around all day,
all night to do them, you know,
sometimes three minutes,
sometimes whatever. And uh,
your first minute is going to make or
break you for the most part if you're
doing a short set.
So doing three minutes set
is enough practice cause
that first minute is the key
because as soon as you get,
it's like a first impression of anything.
If you get onstage and you
have power and you have status,
it doesn't really matter after that.
But if you go on stage apologetic
and scared and codependent, yeah.
Even the best materials and Obama.
Yeah. So I say that first minute,
it's kind of what counts
the most. So, um, so, uh,
doing three spots a night for eight weeks
and recording your sets and listening
to them, uh, not only to sort
of get it into your memory,
but also to see what's
really getting laughs.
Sometimes we hear that we're bombing,
we're actually getting laughs
or we hear the lots are smaller.
It's just important to listen to it back.
You're actively later when you're not
sort of in the sort of deer in the
headlights. Yes. And um,
and then the day of when I do an hour
at night or when I do two hours a night,
when I'm doing,
I'm getting ready for my hour.
I don't leave my hotel room and I
don't talk all day, which is like,
I try not to talk on the phone.
I try not to just deplete too much of my
energy so that I'm super excited to get
on stage and talk so that
I almost am like, uh,
what would the metaphor be
like? Um, a boiling pot?
No. Of Balloon? No, I'm not sure what
you're going to be either of those.
Depends what comes up. I mean like when
you're like chomping at the bit. Yeah.
You know,
I kind of deprive myself.
It's almost like starving
yourself before meal. You know?
Like I kinda like sit in my hotel
room all day. I just do work.
I don't talk on the phone so that I'm
super amped to talk. So I would say like,
don't go out to dinner first. Don't
go to lunch, hang out, watch TV. Yes.
Exactly. Deprive yourself. So
by the time you get onstage,
you're just like super connected and
human connection you have all day. Yes.
Craving intimacy, you
know, instead of shutdown.
And you've already filled your,
um, quota for connection all day.
And when do you know that your material
is ready for three minutes set?
In other words,
someone that hasn't even done the,
what's funny about a garbage can. Yeah.
Like we're talking, it's like RF Ferris,
you're on in an hour. Do I get up and
do, what the fuck do I talk about? Well,
here's the thing. You're already,
you're already naturally funny,
so you're and you're smarts, so you're
going to be fine because you're going to,
I mean, uh, um, pending any, uh,
anxiety attacks.
I think I'm the only funny one. I'm
not trying to be fun. Here's the thing,
I feel like you are a public
speaker naturally. I mean,
you're very good at this.
Like, I mean in front of a crowd, I mean,
you're not gonna have a problem. Um,
and you're going to react to the situation
and be honest and self deprecate and
whatever or like,
um,
but I think the only time you really get
in trouble is when you attach yourself
to a script and are flexible,
right? So if you're like,
go off on a thing of, Oh, you know who I
am, you read my, if someone heckles you,
I've read your book and now you're right.
And then you're like,
so I was at the supermarket today.
And if you can't respond
in a conversational,
present way, it's like boxing. Yep.
Like if someone throws some new,
you got to change your
combination or whatever it is.
You have to be relentlessly present.
And flexible and detached from your plan.
So it's make a plan and
then be ready to completely
adaptive, adaptive needed with
the your essay two hours a night.
Yeah. Right. Let's see. You're getting
now you're getting ready. Do that. And uh,
well two I guess two
very related questions.
So you have the two hours a night in
preparation for like recording the big
special yes. Is that right? Yes.
Then you have like the night of
recording the big special yes.
What are your pregame rituals look like?
Love it.
Like in the two hours before each
of those? Yeah. What happened?
So in the two hour,
okay.
So I am right now I'm touring
to get ready for my HBO special,
which I'm shooting in August. So every
other weekend I'm on the road. Uh,
in clubs I like to a performance,
small spaces to really ascertain if
things are working and seeing people's
faces. Like, cause you can, in a
theater you can get an applause break,
but when you're up close and you
see someone you can't fake laughter,
you can't fake it, bottle
it. Imagine if you have
30 people, if you have 200 people,
10 people clap really loudly,
you think you're killing it.
Whereas if you have 30 people in,
one person clapped yet.
Oh Shit.
Yeah, exactly. So, but
if you get a theater,
you get sort of this false sense of
bravado and false sense of success.
Whereas like when you're in a club,
like people are drinking and
they're eating at, you know,
it's like you're up against more.
So I like to practice in clubs and uh,
and so when the day actually
comes, I will, I have two dogs.
I will send them with the dog people
so that they're not in the house, um,
for those two days because they'll wake
me up early or the whole, you know,
whatever. Um, even though they provide
me with a lot of emotional support, um,
just avoiding any curve balls. Um, and
I'll wake up, I'll do my normal routine.
I'll probably,
I'll listen to the set a couple times,
even though I know it inside and out,
just more, because I know I'm neurotic.
So this is a previous performance.
I'd like the hour that I'm planning
on doing essentially like the script.
It's like going over a script.
I have it recorded and I'll go for a run,
probably got it.
And with it in my year,
the recording is you reading the script
or according as an actual performance.
I got it.
So I'll record all of my hours when
I'm in the clubs on a voice memo on my
iPhone and then I'll label them. This
was good at this point. This, you know,
I did this new chunk of this. I'll be
really specific about which one is which.
The one that I feel should
be the one that's recorded.
I will go for a run and
listen to it in my I Pod Pad,
pad phone, Samsung, sidekick, Atari,
just a five phones page or
pager, sky, pager. And then um,
I'll kind of lie in bed. I'll take a nap,
I'll eat. Uh, and that's pretty much it.
Got It.
And then I have to get there at four for
hair and makeup and I'll meditate twice,
20 minutes in the morning, 20 minutes
before the show, like trends and all that.
You got your mantra, mantra? Yeah.
Don't tell anyone. Help me. Joe Public.
Oh my God,
I can't believe we're sitting outside
and, uh, really, um,
very economical with my energy,
the death.
And so you've got the,
let's just say the warmup acts new.
That's probably not, that's
probably not a polite way to say it,
but the opening scene, mark got
the openers. You know, you're,
you've got 15 minutes to go time. Yeah.
What do you do in those 15 minutes?
That's a good question.
Uh,
I'm usually managing a or
practicing wardrobe malfunctions.
So practicing like Janet
Jackson nipple exposure. Yeah.
I'll walk through sort of my most extreme
movements with my wardrobe, right.
To make sure you know, like, you know what
I mean? Uh, it's uh, what's it called?
Like, um, catastrophe, a troubleshooting.
Yeah. Actually, you know,
um, I'll just close my eyes and meditates.
Troubleshooting other residents.
Catastrophe sniping. Yeah.
I took what I could touch.
The reason I think I like that.
Um,
and then sometimes something super
normal because I think I'm, you know,
I'm a strong believer in this.
Everybody is,
I'm not special cause I believe proven
science, but it's very Pavlovian.
So it's like all of a sudden I'm doing
something I've never done before before a
show,
then it's gonna feel weird.
So before I go on stage at the comedy
store tonight, on any given night,
I'm looking at Instagram,
I'm on Twitter, I'm texting,
so I'll do something just kind of,
that I always do before I
go on stage because if you
put too much pressure on it,
like this is a different show.
Your,
I'm doing the same thing I've been doing
the last four months. Right, right, right.
You know what I mean? And it's like, it's
basically my, my work isn't done tonight.
My work was done three months ago.
Right, right. I just have to show up.
Yeah. I had, um, conversation with,
uh, with, uh, Paul Levesque
of residents, triple h,
the professional wrestler who was on his
podcast and he was telling me a story,
uh, why am I blanking here? He just fought
Manny Pacquiao or Floyd Mayweather Jr.
Yeah. And he was saying, he was
telling me a story about how he,
he visited Floyd in his dressing
or right before a huge fight.
And he was just sitting there watching TV
and he's like, oh yeah, sit down. Like,
let's have a conversation. And then
Paul's like, I don't want to bother
you. Like, I don't want you to get
knocked out of the zone and blah, blah,
aren't you nervous? And he's like, what
good is being nervous is going to do me.
It's like,
if I'm not ready now,
yeah, hundred percent. So it's like, if
I need to do some weird ritual right now,
then I'm the, I big got bigger problems.
Yeah. You know? So I think for me,
just keeping it very simple and, um,
you know, if I'm shooting a special,
my mom and dad or they have
to come different nights,
but, um, we'll come salt,
like take a picture for that or
something that just feels benevolent and,
and connected. And I, you know,
I'm very dorky about gratitude and I'll
just be grateful and I'll thank the crew
and I'll talk to my director and just
say thank you and like just really do
whatever I have to do to go out there
and just like, have a good time.
I'm not taking myself seriously.
I'm not stressed, I'm not in a zone.
It's like I know this backwards
and forwards at this point.
So the only work I have to do
is just be relentlessly present.
And this sounds so Geeky, but I truly
have to have a good time. Yeah. Um,
because my work is already
done. Right. You know,
that's kind of the misery of standup
and the joy of standup is that the,
when you're actually shooting it on TV,
you're just showing off at that point.
There's no, you're not in the trenches.
Yeah. You know, everything works.
You've done it. I, anything
I do on showing that I've
done a hundred times. Right.
And I know it works
well. That's part of the reason I
love watching and I've seen, you know,
Brian do this, but work on
material. Yeah. When it's not 100%.
Yeah, I find that fascinating. It's pretty
cool. Yeah, it's really, there is a,
if you're a comedy nerd in any way,
uh,
Kevin Nealon does a show at the laugh
factory on Tuesday nights and it's new
material night. This is in loss of
in Los Angeles. Yes. So, um, and I,
but I think they put videos on the laugh
factory website or something and it's
Comedians,
you know,
big comedians who are only allowed to
do new material and we will call each
other out if I'm like, dude, I know
you've been doing that joke and I know,
you know,
cause we really try to be vulnerable and
go up and do sort of fresh premises and
then some of us are bombing and you know,
we're really struggling and it's like
being a beginner open miker again.
Have you seen the documentary, the
comedian Jerry Seinfeld and Warnie? Yes.
What is,
how do you feel about [inaudible]
I love it. I love it. I love Jerry.
I think his work ethic is really,
um, he just kind of nailed it. I mean,
you know about this more
than anyone obviously,
but his whole thing is just do the
work. It's, yeah, there's no shortcuts.
There's no, um, you know,
there's a linear relationship and stand
up of how much you do it and how good
you are. It's super simple,
very merit driven. Um,
and so I like that.
I like his methodical approach.
I've learned a lot from him and been
inspired by that. And he's also, you know,
I think it's good to glamorize health
cause I think in stand up especially,
um, uh, drug addiction and alcoholism
is so glamorized, you know,
in Jerry's Kinda,
he does yoga and drink smoothies and
he's doesn't drink on stage. You know,
he takes it very seriously,
stand up as a job.
And I think a lot of people
see it more as a hobby. Um,
cause we all really just secretly want
to be rock stars but aren't cool enough.
Um,
but you know,
I think there was this generation of
comedians obviously in the 70s, 80s,
who were all on coke and hookers and now
I think the pendulum has kind of swung,
everyone's like in therapy. And Drinks
Jamba juice and things like vegan.
And I think that Jerry in
that documentary sort of him
admitting how seriously he takes it.
Yeah.
Like the nerd in the class who gets a
straight A and all the jocks hate like,
who's a loser. Like it's high school
all over again. Yeah. You know,
it's like he makes trying look cool.
Yeah. Um, and then Arnie, you know,
I think it's tricky because he just was
so angry in that documentary and I, I,
I worry a little bit that people were
like, oh, that's how all comedians are.
Right.
You know?
But it's a documentary and if someone
thinks that that's their generalization.
Yeah. Yeah. But warranty
is very, very funny.
And I think that that documentary,
um, was a big, uh, what was it?
What would it be when something
is, um, uh, injury to his career?
Yeah. Yeah. I think he would have
been really big if it was [inaudible].
Yeah. That was a fascinating documentary
for those who haven't seen it,
but it's basically tracking.
Yeah.
A younger up and coming comedian
with Jerry working on new material.
Yes. Uh, yes. And a friend's ex
girlfriend actually popped up. Yeah,
I was watching it with him and he's
like, wait, what is that like? No, no.
She popped up.
It was just her leading Jerry to the stage
and he's like, wait a second.
Was that, it's not my girlfriend.
Yeah. Really bizarre shilling
a twist. Let me ask, um,
I don't want to chew up
your entire afternoon. Uh,
this is, this is really fun.
So maybe we'll do round two some time,
but I'd love to ask you a number one.
Equine therapy.
Yes.
Well, my therapy, the horse rides you.
Is that when you, how does this work? No,
that's Ashley Madison. Oh, that's the
how we've been through that. Catherine.
The Great. Yeah. Right. So, um,
okay. Actually sounded a little much.
It did not come out the
way I intended it to Sarah.
That that's my attempt to blue
comedy. And I think, you know,
a successful a time, so I don't
think you'd have to wait a week.
You should go on tonight. You can
be my warm up and he makes me angry.
Horses riding women talk about it. So I, I
think this might interest you
or interest you because, um,
and I hope that I do justice to it and
explain it in a educated enough way to
her. It doesn't sound ridiculous,
but horses are prey animals.
So they are incredibly attuned to
any kind of threats. I mean it's,
I mean they're constantly scanning for
threats, which the human brain does also.
And we try to like pretend it's not,
but essentially,
I mean constantly they owe a horse can
look at a bobcat and tell if it's hungry
or not. I mean it's fight or
flight one on one. You know,
they can literally read
faces they can read. Um,
so when you are around a horse,
a horse is codependent,
if you will, uh, looking at you and their
behavior depends on your behavior. Um,
so essentially what you do in equine
therapy is it's my goal was to practice
being more direct and clear with my
intention versus what I'm asking someone.
Cause you know,
a lot of times,
and you can't see this if you're listening
to this podcast, but I'll say like, um,
no, I'm fine. I'm not mad. I'm
obviously mad. I mean I don't my face,
I'm, I'm betraying my
own face. And you know,
humans tend to be manipulative and passive
aggressive and say one thing and mean
another thing. And I think
that's something, you know,
that maybe people in my field maybe do
more than you know, you and what you do.
You seem very like clear and effective.
Great actor,
pathological liar, sociopath, American
psycho, American history X. Um,
but I found that I was really struggling
with not being with saying one thing
and meaning another thing and being
apologetic and not being present and not
getting the results out
of people that I wanted.
There was a great documentary called
Buck. That's about the guy. Yes.
It's about the guy that
was the horse whisper.
And essentially the whole premise of the
documentary is that in order to control
something,
you have to give it more control.
So in order to get power over someone,
you have to empower them.
So people bring these problem horses and
they pulling them and trying to control
them and the first thing he does is
give them more rains and give them the
opportunity to make the right decision
so you can control something when you
give them more control.
So that really fascinated me,
that documentary and the way that he
was able to nonverbally communicate with
horses because we waste so
much time trying to verbally
communicate with people.
And a lot of times we just confused them.
And words are so subjective and um,
we talk way too much so people don't
actually understand what we're saying. Uh,
you know, I don't know if this has
ever happened to you, but I, you know,
a lot of times when I'm
writing a script or a TV show,
I'll get notes from an executive and I'll,
you know,
I'm sure your editors or whatever,
I'll be in a meeting for an hour and I'll
walk out and I'm like, I have no idea.
No idea.
We spoke for an hour.
I have no clue what my objective is.
I don't know what the notes are.
I don't know if they liked it,
like we just bloviate to the point
of just like be talking in circles.
So, um, I went in, um, uh,
with the horses, uh, a girlfriend
of mine took me for my birthday.
And the first thing you do is you
pick a horse and there's four horses.
They all various degrees
of damage and backgrounds,
and she tells you about each
one and you choose your horse,
which already says everything that she
needs to know about you based on the one
that you choose.
It's like a word shock test or something.
So that's really interesting.
And then the first objective is get
the horses from one end to the, uh, uh,
corral to the other, which is probably
like half of a football field. I mean,
it's big and you're like,
how am I going to, hello?
What's the best phone that's
about phone? Um, that's, uh,
Ashley Madison Customer Service. Uh,
so I'm like, how do you get a heart?
How do you get horses with no rain from
one end to the other? Right. Right.
This is crazy. Without controlling
them or hitting them or, uh,
you can't use treats. I can't use any of
my, I can't use charm. I can't use humor.
I can't use intelligence. I can't
use any of the things that I rely on,
on a daily basis to manipulate
and beguile people. Right?
And so essentially you have to use your
intention so you let them know we're
going to the other end.
You can use words if you want,
as long as you're saying something and
meaning it, they're going to buy it.
If you're going, you know, you can't see
me doing this, but if you're going like,
I need you to come with me. Is that
okay? If you're asked, there are no,
there aren't clear. They don't
trust you. You're not in charge.
You don't have status.
So I go and I'm,
I'm leading them from
one end to the other.
They're following me and it's like magic.
They're following me.
And then halfway through I
start like to see my friend,
I've got to following me and they
stopped and I was like, Whoa,
what just happened? She, she's like,
you lost your connection to them because
you focused on something else. I mean,
it was just this, like, it was like magic
almost. It was this amazing. So I just,
it's a way to practice being present
and connected and having a consistent
intention with essentially these sort of
animals that are basically a mirror to
your psyche. That's very cool. It's super
cool when they, when you stop focusing,
they stop focusing and whenever you lie,
they freeze because they
don't understand why.
Because they just see
she's mean something,
but she's saying something
else and they freeze.
So as soon as you're disingenuous or
pretend you're not scared and you are,
they just freeze and look at you
like, don't get it. They're just like,
grow up and you're like, oh, sorry. Let me
be clear. You know, it's this really cool,
uh, sort of, um, way that I think, and
I'm not saying I'm one of these people,
but I think that smart people who
have so much therapy and we've so over
therapize sometimes it's just like,
keep it simple. Bread and butter.
Another animal in a cage. Yeah. Yes or no.
It's so primal and simple.
I've almost learned so much from that
than any other book or therapy I've ever
done.
That's a for those people interested in,
uh,
a lot of this stuff I'm really tempted to,
to experience that.
It's here, it's in the, the woman that I
go to is out in Topanga and it's awesome.
Cool. It's called the
reflective horse, you know,
a lot of rehab patients do equine therapy.
Um,
while I was going, I was going
to say that, uh, reflective,
I think it's reflective, reflective
for us, I'm taking notes, uh,
is temple Grandin worked a lot with
horses early on and that's how she started
to realize like, wow, I'm actually very
good at understanding what they need,
what they're afraid of, et
cetera. Um, so fast now,
and you mentioned book and then you said
therapy. So I'll ask you a question,
which is, what book or books have
you gifted to other people the most?
Ooh,
that's a great question.
I like to pretend that I read
fiction and I just don't.
Okay. So I went through
this phase of giving people,
cause I read one fiction book in the
last like three years called Super Sad,
true love story by Gary Shrank Art,
which is phenomenal. Super Sad,
true love story.
Gary Sign Guard.
It's super sad but very
funny and I'm not super,
it's,
it's um,
it's like a dystopian satire on the future
and essentially it's like that we all
have cell phones sort of
embedded in our chest. And um,
as soon as I see you, I can know
everything about you, your cholesterol,
your genetics, your dad had a stroke.
Like I can know at your bank account,
your credit report.
Like essentially we know everything about
everyone instantaneously and it's just
very interesting and like could happen.
Uh,
and I read that because I had to,
because a friend of mine who's sort of
successful and has everything and had a
birthday weekend and you can't
get or anything. So her gift,
our gift to her was we all had to read
the same book, which was so annoying.
Don't be friends with rich celebrities.
Um, it was like your homework.
And I was like so annoyed and an
ended up obviously being excellent.
Gary Shine Guard is phenomenal.
So I started giving it to everyone
more as an ego, as a conglomerate,
as I read fiction guys.
Like I'm so every night I'm so
cultured and as a pat on the back.
But I don't want to mislead you into
thinking I actually read fiction.
I'm not that um, normal. Uh, I, you,
I give the drama of the gifted child
a lot, uh, to people. You know,
this book has come up,
I bet you just in the last week
with a number of very talented,
yeah, high performers. Yes. Drama,
the drama of the gifted child.
It's very much,
yes. If you're a creative person, um,
if you have any kind of anxiety
or discomfort or just read it,
it's hard to sum up.
Uh,
another one I give a
lot is the fantasy bond,
which is incredibly dense and clinical,
but it's about,
uh,
essentially what happens between ages
one and three sort of ordained your whole
life. It's kind of about attachment, um,
like our attachment strategies based on
how much eye contact we got as a child,
how we were breastfed,
how much physical contact we got,
what our dynamics we walked
into as a child, and uh,
how we see the world according
to those formative years,
which is pretty fascinating
stuff. Um, about,
you know,
I think is when you're,
I think I have a lot of shame around the
fact that I'm almost like an attention
seeker, if that makes any
sense. Like being a comedian,
there's just a little bit of
shame for me when it's like,
why do I have this much of a compulsion
to be seen and heard? Like what is this?
And once I got a got a handle on the fact
that as a kid I wasn't seen and heard
enough and I had this,
I was trying to get these childhood
needs met as an adult through my,
once I got a handle on that understanding,
it made me need it less. Right.
You know, I was like, oh my God, I don't
want to be famous. What am I doing?
This is horrible. I'm like, you can't
undo this. You know, so I feel like,
you know, I, because I read this book,
I took like a year off of like being
on TV cause I didn't need that anymore.
It wasn't like I just need to be seen
as much as possible by as many people as
possible. That's not unhealthy
compulsion. And, and I,
that backfired in some ways.
So I was able to kind of take
control of my self. The fantasy bond.
You the fantasy Mont it's um, Firestone
rubber Firestone. Maybe it's, yeah,
it was recommended by, um,
Mark Marin. Actually the, the,
the epitome of mental health.
Mark is in large part responsible for me
wanting to experiment with podcasting.
It's so cool. It's such a great
experience on his podcast. Yeah.
Joe Rogan's podcast, the Nerdist
podcast. I was like, oh yeah, one thing.
It's really fun. Yeah. All my faves.
Yeah. So we were on tour together last
summer and he was reading it and uh,
I was sort of,
I think things come in your life exactly
when you need them kind of thing.
Like this book, the job and the
gifted child. Maybe there's something,
someone obviously want the universe wants
you to read this book I guess. But, uh,
I was just didn't a receptive moment and
he was reading it and I was like boom.
And it was just the perfect time. Cool.
Like, you know, I'll check it out.
So I've been giving those,
uh,
another good one because a
lot of my friends having kids,
it's called the continuum concept and
it's about sort of attachment parenting.
Is this
basically like you don't, you
keep the kid with you 24, seven,
it's all they crawl away kind of thing.
Yes. And the point is, what was it called?
The continuum. Continuum concept. Okay.
And oddly it was recommended by my
equine therapy teacher and it's about
essentially the reason we,
there's all sorts of chemical reasons
like dopamine and oxytocin that are given
off when we touch each other and
especially people we love and bond with.
But that if you always go
to a child when they cry,
they learn. If I need something,
my needs will get met,
I can trust that someone
else will meet my needs.
So attachment parenting is when
your child cries, you go to them,
you can't necessarily solve their problem,
but they know that their voice is
being heard and they feel heard.
So they're more secure, they're
more trusting of their environment.
They don't deny their
own reality as adults,
essentially their expectations
for the rest of their future. So
why did your, if you don't,
let me ask you. Sure.
Equine therapy instead of going to
say x, I was like, oh no, no, no.
Why did your the
equine therapy recommend
that? Yeah, we um,
we're talking about attachment I think,
and we were talking about like,
oh the horse.
Like I,
I didn't have trust that the horse
was going to follow me or something.
Like I was like kept
checking in and she's like,
you keep cause equine therapy
is so fascinating because
of what comes up the way
that we, uh, relate to.
It just says so much about how we try to
run businesses, marriages, relationships.
It's just a metaphor for everything
because of the way you do anything is the
way you do everything.
Right.
So I kept checking in and doubting that
the reality that the horse was following
me, I was like incredulous that
it was happening. And she's like,
you really question reality.
You always doubt yourself and you think
that your perception is wrong and that
you know that the Damocles
sword is going to fall.
You're always looking for the catastrophe.
And so she was like read this book and
I did to kind of get an understanding of
like, oh, something must have happened.
That may be constantly be like,
and it's true.
I'm always waiting for the other shoe
to drop when something's going well.
I'm just like looking around and
said I'm enjoying the moment.
I'm just waiting for the catastrophe,
you know?
So it was sort of about
all that blue comedy
really confusing to me and the expression
waiting for the other shoe to drop.
And I'm just like,
I interesting.
Well cause you know what I always think
of when I think of waiting for the other
shoe to drop his shoes on a
phone line in a bad neighborhood.
What do you think that means?
Wait a second. You know,
what do I think of your envisioning?
That means wait.
Okay.
I always think of bad,
she was in the neighborhood when I think
of waiting for the other shoe to drop.
That's the vision that
comes to mind. Yeah. Also,
do you know what it means when shoes
are hanging in a bad neighborhood?
I don't know. You've seen it,
right? I always thought it
was just kids being dicks.
But martial artist,
I think I'm probably totally wrong
apparently. Right. It's cause you know,
like in a photo you'll see a fall in line,
you'll see a pair of sneakers
hanging in bad neighborhoods.
Apparently it's where someone
died of heroin. So you know,
that's where the best heroin is. So when
people see shoes hanging, thank you.
I got it. Right. Ninja. I got an injury
on an approved Hashtag on it. Um,
and then you know,
that's where you should buy heroin.
Cause that's the purest stuff cause
it killed someone. That's insane.
Insane blue comedy.
That's Travis brewer. I,
he brewer making a cameo.
Uh,
when you think of the word successful,
who's the first person that comes to mind?
Steve Jobs. Steve Jobs. Is that weird?
I like him anyway though.
So that was like on the
tip of my brain brain when,
okay. However, if you had, if you
had to choose a second person,
uh, it has to be the tip of my
brain does not, I'm overthinking it.
Well,
I was just going to say something that
is just going to open up a weird can of
worms because I was
Gunna say Shel Sandberg,
cause I feel like she had this well
rounded life and a personal life also, um,
which recently imploded,
um, which is not funny.
Uh,
but like someone who had,
I think I used to define success as
someone at the top of their field
professionally only.
And now I also view it as someone who has
balanced like a good relationship with
friends and family.
You know,
time has fun. Uh, when they're not
working, they're actually not working.
Um, so that's why I was thinking
about her and Drew Barrymore.
This is really weird,
but I follow her on Instagram.
She really seems to go to the beach a lot.
She's got a cosmetic less,
she has two kids. She seemed to have
kind of nailed it. I was just like, God,
it's just, that must be
nice. Um, Steve Johnson,
Drew Barrymore, that's you know, and
Sheryl Sandberg, that's a Trifecta.
Motley Crue.
Elon Musk is a good one.
I mean I don't really know about his
personal life, but he's in terms of,
you know, making an impact. I think
he's probably done a pretty good job.
Yes, you're pretty successful. He's,
he's very good at betting the
farm and pulling it off. Yeah.
Like I mean I think you made 180 million
from the sale of paypal and he took all
of it and put it into three companies
and had to borrow money for rent.
Yeah.
He's like a bill burr.
He keeps making himself poor so
he has to get rich again. Yeah.
Like how to fill bombs in comparison yet.
You know,
cause it's interesting cause I want to,
all these comedians came to mind.
Like I was thinking Richard Pryor and
Louis C K and Jerry Seinfeld and I,
all these comedians were coming to mind.
But I think for me,
because I've seen the other,
what the success has cost
them. Yeah. You, you know,
how the sausage is made.
Yes.
So I don't know a lot or Steve jobs
is what it costs them emotionally,
family wise. So I'm a little
bit naive about it. Yeah.
So in job's case a lot. A Lot,
I'm sure. Well, cause yeah,
and it was interesting
because everybody always,
I think the reason I sort
of latched on to him,
I mean it's obviously a
pretty hacky on original, uh,
inspiring figure. But I think when
I was the boss for the first time,
I think I for some reason looked up to
him in a way because everyone was like,
oh, he's an asshole. He's
crazy. And I was like, I just,
maybe everyone who's the US is crazy
because no one likes their boss because
they're telling them to do work, you
know? And I remember people were like, oh,
he was such a Dick. Like he would,
you know, if something wasn't perfect,
he'd make them fix it. And I'd be
like, oh, what's so wrong with that?
What you're supposed to do. I mean,
that sounds like a great boss, you know,
he sounds like a great leader,
you know?
And I hear all these horror stories and
I think that I started getting paranoid
that people thought I was difficult.
And I do, you know? And I'm like,
why is it difficult to say I
think we can do better? Yeah.
I think we can beat this
joke. Like I'm not, I'm just
like, I want this to be good.
All of our names are on it.
You're getting paid a tremendous
amount of money to be here.
Why am I such a jerk?
You know?
And I think that through the lens of
people's Egos and, and feelings and stuff,
it just ends up being like, oh, he's
crazy. He's an asshole. You know?
I'm yet to meet or know of one successful
person who everyone doesn't think is
crazy.
Yeah, yeah. Right. Yeah. It's pretty much
just means they're par for the course.
Yeah. Generally speaking.
Yeah. He's crazy. He's fucking
notice a psycho. It's like,
okay. Or are you just catch someone on an
off day? You know what I mean? Like, I've,
I've met some people who are celebrities
who in person every time I've seen them
in interaction with other people with me,
they've been great.
But I'd read things about them
online at some point where, you know,
someone's like, oh my God, you know,
I was touring with this guy and
he wouldn't sign fans, autographs.
He was a dick that it, I'm
like, maybe just had a bad day.
I like how you broke up
with his girlfriend or like,
who the hell knows it was in
the airport. And um, you know,
people were asking for pictures and I,
my dad had just had a stroke and I
was like, I'm just sorry I can't.
And I'm sure that those people are
going, she's such an asshole. Like,
I'm sure they were, you know, but it's
just not, you know, we just can't concern.
What do you think of me is none of my
business, et cetera. You know, Louis C K,
I don't know if you know
this, it interests me. Uh,
he doesn't take photos with people,
but he says,
I won't take a photo with you but I
will talk to you for five minutes.
And he says, almost
everybody declined. Oh,
I bet they just want the photo now. Why
doesn't he do the photos? I don't know.
I think it's, I don't remember. I guess,
I guess maybe it's like if
you're going to occupy this time,
I want you to have to
do some work as well.
Maybe like what am I going to get
out of this? Well, no, not even that,
but it's just, you know, if we're going
to have an exchange that's an exchange.
Let's, if you want to connect, let's
really connect. I think, I mean,
I'm sure he has a really interesting
reason why he doesn't. Um,
but uh, I think because also
it's like there's no, you know,
I say getting your picture
taken is just so weird. I mean,
especially on like a press
line. Like, you know,
an actress has have to go down a
press line and just like pose, I said,
I mean I've stopped kind
of doing it cause I'm like,
unless someone gives me a healthy inner
monologue to recite while I'm doing that,
I'm not going to do it. Cause
what are you, you're just like,
look at me and my sexy, my thin
enough. Do you want to say like,
it's just such unhealthy things that
you're thinking what's in my head every
time I read somewhere
that you ride the subway.
So it's like,
I'm sure when he's posing with someone,
it's just like you just in San Francisco,
it's kind of like the Mad Max
Marauder version of the subway.
I like that outdoor one.
And who would you ever carpet
a place is filthy car? I Dunno.
It's not the trolley. No
anything. Yeah, exactly.
They get along
hyperloop,
the hyper carpet hypercarbia load.
Hypercarbia and uh, so I think that, yeah,
I think he just felt like he feels like,
you know,
you can feel kind of violated someone
just ambushing you. And, I mean,
he's with his kids and he's, you
know, I think when you have a family,
I can only imagine if one person gets one,
then all of a sudden everybody wants
one and then you're going to, you know,
so I think he just, you
know, whatever, for whatever
reason, I'm sure he has a, um,
you know, dignified reason
for it. But nobody ever, like,
I mean to talk to Louis
C K for five minutes,
it could be the best five minutes of your
life. And people are like, no thanks.
We just want, I just wanted to Instagram,
I didn't show off that I met you.
This is about me. It's not about you.
I mean this like culture of narcissism.
I remember I was at the
People's choice awards,
which is like a really silly
award show. Um, but you know,
they have seat fillers,
fillers. The fillers is like,
there's all the celebrities there,
but then everyone else that's
in the audience are like
paid seat fillers who are
super attractive and it's like
an Indonesian political round.
Yeah, absolutely. That's
so funny. Yeah, no,
I didn't know that.
I love you and I as reference points are
so different and yours are so much more
impressive. Um, and uh,
so they get paid 50 bucks to dress pretty
and look good because they're going to
be on camera, maybe in a pan shot or
something. And so I'm sitting in front of,
I want to say Allen's in front of me,
but Ellen had gone on stage,
so this is actually so, but there's
all these seat fillers. A Beautiful,
I can't tell who the,
I mean the seat fillers are more attracted
than celebrities. I mean, it's like, um,
and so on stage, is that what I say?
Ellen and Chris Pine, who was that?
You know, whatever actor, a famous actor.
And I see these people holding up
their cameras and I'm like looking at,
we're trying to look over them and
I see that they're taking selfies of
themselves. And I'm like, no,
the celebrities are that way.
You're not the celebrity. I mean, people,
there's a celebrity two feet in front
of them and they're taking a picture of
themselves. Yeah. I mean
it's just like, you know,
it was crazy. Yeah. It's a
bizarre flip it around. Yeah.
It's a bizarre world we live in. Yeah.
Just to just a few last questions.
You could put a billboard anywhere and
have anything you want on the billboard
texts photo. What would
it be? Where would it be?
Like a message I would want to get out
or message or it could be a photo of
anything. Anything. Wow. This
is a really good question.
You should have a podcast. Um, if I could,
well,
everyone's got their things right there.
Thing causes and my cause is dogs.
That's, everyone's got their
thing and I'm sure that, you know,
when something else touches me
that will be my thing. You know,
and cancer touches my family or whatever.
Alcoholism has touched my family,
but I haven't been compelled to
like get super in the trenches of,
of that.
But I'm a statistic that really affected
me to statistics that I just sort of
wish people knew was that 3 million dogs
die a year in shelters and 17 million a
year get bought.
So it's just like
the three. Shouldn't it crazy math. Yeah,
it should be. Don't make me do this math.
Yeah. 14 a year I bought that should
just be the statistic. Right. So,
uh, that was something that just
hearing that I was like, God,
that is such a waste.
That's just so much death and it's just
so karmically bad for just this species.
And so, um, uh, so yeah, that's
something that's sort of one,
I was always kind of trying to do dog
rescue and I didn't really know how.
And once I got that statistic, I felt
kind of emboldened to be like, all right,
I know exactly where my energy can go.
It was very empowering to learn that.
And another thing is,
um,
I work with this a charity called
the Beagle freedom project. Um,
that's bagels that are tested on in labs,
um,
that the tests are usually an ain
and like don't do much. It's just,
you can say a product is tested
on an animal and that it's safe.
And this statistic kind of blew my mind,
which is that beagles are chosen to be,
um,
the dog's tested on in labs because
they're the most forgiving of all dog
breeds.
So you can hurt them a bunch of times
and they'll still give you the benefit of
the doubt and they'll still keep
forgiving you. Heartbreaking.
So once I heard that, I was like, I'm in,
you're preying on the weakest, sweetest.
And so I got involved in that and uh,
you know,
I think that if you don't have
kids, you know, and if you're busy,
like you and I are and you travel a lot,
dogs is just a really sort of easy,
rewarding sort of healthy
thing and those two.
So I feel like I would just
put those on billboards maybe
in China at the dog meat festival.
That's probably the location I would pick.
The Yulin dog meat festival.
It makes me crazy. Is there a dog be fest?
Oh my God. The Yulin dog meat festival.
Yeah. So, uh, this obviously means
you don't follow me on Instagram. Um,
which is Stop Ulan 2015 is my, a
big obsession right now. But yeah,
there's a dog meat festival that's
going on I think right now in China, uh,
where they actually kidnapped
people's domesticated dogs.
So you just wake up and
your dogs are gone. And then
there's a dog meat festival.
It's, I mean, here's the thing with China,
they don't treat their
people that great either.
I'm much less their dogs
or their children. So, uh,
that's a bigger issue that I'm not really
qualified to talk about. But yeah. Wow.
Dog me Puzzle. But whenever I tell
people whenever I'm like doing,
I think a lot of people want to help dogs.
It's just such an or animals or cats,
anything too big of an issue.
And like as soon as they hear that,
like beagles the most that people like,
how do I help?
And a lot of people don't even know
they're getting arrested on the goals.
The goals are the most tested on dog
species. They're also the most forgiving.
What'd you call ms.com buy tickets.
There we go. Download my stuff off.
Delo myself. No, I'm using it.
Actually donate. Donate just to me.
I just got this to get your attention.
I just wanted to capture your heart so
then I could then manipulate you into
buying me a vacation home. Gotcha. Gotcha.
That's political circle research. It's
like, I'm glad you asked that question.
Let me
also think that like donating to animals
is just my drug of choice. I guess.
I don't drink, I drank,
but I'm not, you know,
not like to access and I know do drugs
like when I give money to and I feel as
good. So I just feel like a lot of
people, like once they start it's,
you feel good if you give 20 bucks
to whatever, you know, it's like,
I think everyone would be,
everybody wins.
What advice would you give
to your 25 year old self?
25. Uh, there's so much advice.
I would say don't wear any of what
you're wearing right now, which was,
which was, you know, it's funny,
I dressed like a boy from the 70s
until I was like 29 new vintage,
new balance sneakers, bell bottoms,
and a Hoodie with a backpack. You know,
I was very, that was my uniform. Um,
which was kind of like my shield of like,
please don't see me as a sexual being.
Like when I did stand up, you know,
I tried to really like neutralize my,
like gender, um, and uh,
stop drinking diet coke,
stopped drinking aspartame.
I feel like I just missed
the new thing of that.
That was like my early twenties in
college was all artificial sweeteners and
crap that I feel like I'm going to be,
that's why I'm drinking
the stupid beet juice. Um,
and I think it really compromise
my productivity and my, you know,
who knows what that was doing to
my brain chemistry. Um, and uh,
I think maybe the main thing is those
mistakes are actually getting you to
exactly where you want to go.
They're rerouting you to your dreams,
you know, and they're not, I hate
the word failure because I always,
I always think it's just like a step
in the right direction, you know?
So all the things that I agonized
over the jobs I didn't get.
I mean I like was in bed,
like crying my eyes out for like a week
cause I didn't get it job as a VH one,
like host of account down.
I mean something that would
just be so embarrassing.
If you saw my Wikipedia page day,
I'd be like,
can we really don't talk about that?
It would have been a thing that I said,
please don't talk about it on the podcast.
So would've been so embarrassing now,
but at the time it was like I was just
the holy grail. I was destroyed over it.
You know what? I didn't
realize, oh my God.
And a couple of years
like I dodged a bullet,
so I wished that I had kind of,
I would have saved a lot of
time and energy and anguish.
Mistakes are taking you where you
want to go. Yes, exactly. Exactly.
This has been great.
Where can people learn more about you?
Ashley Madison Whitehouse.
Dot. Porn. I literally got this call
the other day. My lawyer was like, Hey,
we need to buy your.porn. And I was like,
are we, we changed in the game plan.
Is there something I don't know down?
Yeah,
but dop, the dop, porn is about to come
out, so you have to buy your domain.
You're welcome. Thank you.
Yeah, Yours Tim Ferriss.
Stop Porn we routed to your blog,
to your website. There you go. Uh,
so the homebase is
where should people go?
Uh, well, well my tour dates and
stuff are all Whitney cummings.com.
And then I have Twitter,
Whitney Cummings,
my Instagram is Whitney a Cummings
because Whitney Cummings is a 15 year old
black aspiring singer who
is pretty talented actually.
It has a lot of followers. Thanks to
me in the eyes has posted two photos.
Um, but uh, yeah, Whitney
a Cummings. Got It. Yeah.
And any last ask of the audience,
if you could ask the audience to
do one thing, what would it be?
Um, besides visit the
website. So provocative.
I'm like using birth of my brains.
I never use,
if I could ask the audience to
do one thing, what would it be?
Um, God, that's a really deep
question. I have so many thoughts.
Um,
I mean,
do you do your thing live out loud,
be authentic? I don't know.
Is that you ask that question.
I've having heard your house,
I don't ask it too often.
If you could ask the
audience to do one thing. Um,
watch comedy.
It's good for you.
Okay. No, I'll, I'll dig
on that for a second.
If somebody who's seen comedy
occasionally, but it's not a connoisseur,
wants to enjoy comedy more, get
more out of it. If they're watching,
say a Stan Oh,
special,
what should they pay attention to or
think of to see kind of an extra layer or
ask themselves anything?
I think that there's,
I think look at what offends you.
If something offends you.
Watch Richard Pryor.
Watch Daniel tosh watched the
most incendiary comedians,
Bill Burr,
maybe Louis C k his monologue that he
just did on SNL that there was this outcry
because you talked about pedophiles or
something. If something offends you,
look inward, that's a sign
that there's something there.
What offends someone says a lot
about them. Agreed. You know,
I think it was may west to
said those were shocked easily.
She'd be shocked more often.
I like that. I like that. I love, I have
a huge poster of West in my office. Um,
but uh,
who a lot of people think was a man
and a lot of people think she was wet.
Huh. Interesting. Their original
Rachel Doughlas all, is that her name?
The girl who just pretended to be black?
The Naacp woman? I don't know. Yeah,
she was like, uh, I was on a plane
yesterday. I was way too deep into, uh,
the news. Um, but uh, yeah,
I would say look at what offends you and
it'll probably help you with some self
awareness.
That's great. Yeah. I love
it. Thank you so much for the
time. This is great. Thanks.
All right to be continued.
And until next time,
thanks for listening
folks for all the links,
resources and so on from this episode.
Just go to four hour workweek.com
forward slash podcast to Lou.
The Tim Ferriss show is
brought to you by on it.
I have used on IT products for years.
If you look in my kitchen in my garage,
you will find Alpha brain chewable
Melatonin for resetting my clock when I'm
traveling. Kettlebells battle
ropes may says steel clubs.
It sounds like a torture
chamber and it kind of is.
It's a torture chamber
for self improvement.
And you can see all of my favorite gear
at [inaudible] dot com forward slash
Tim.
That's o,
n n I t.com forward slash Tim and
you can also get a discount on any
supplements, food products. I like
hemp force, I like Alpha brain.
Check it all out on it.com forward slash.
Tim,
this episode is brought to you by
a new sponsor. So listen up folks.
This is a good one because have you ever
wanted to be as powerful as a bullet
wearing Ninja from an 1880s movie or
as flamboyant as big gay Al Big Al when
South Park or a sleek as a black
panther in the Amazon on the hunt? Well,
there's great news because I've been
testing this product that you wrap around
your genitals and it makes you feel
like a superhero and it is called
[inaudible].
That's been the last two to three weeks
traveling with underwear from these guys
and they are comfy.
I gotta tell you,
it feels like a Geisha has giving your
groin a hug and it's not just for dudes.
But if you go to [inaudible] dot com
forward slash Tim, that's m e, e, u n,
d I e s.com forward slash Tim,
you can see all of the underwear
that I've been wearing.
There's some pretty ridiculous ones. And
uh, I will also highlight my favorite,
you'll probably be able to guess which
it is these underwear made from micro
model, which is extruded from Austrian
beechwood trees in the Alps. Yes. Fancy.
And it's two times softer than cotton,
scientifically tested using the Kawabata
method developed in Kyoto. You know,
those Japanese very crafty and uh,
I will say a few things. Number one,
if you go to [inaudible]
dot com forward slash Tim,
you get to see all of these spectacular
underwear that had been wearing.
And I am a bit of an underwear
connoisseur, socks, fashion
sense with sweatpants,
not so much underwear. I
understand. So check them out.
And if you go to [inaudible] dot com
forward slash timber you will also be able
to see lots of hot ladies
wearing BMDS female underwear.
And that's just a lot of goodness for
both the men and the women out there.
So check it out.
[inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim,
I love these underwear and a,
I want it to be packing tonight,
probably six to 12 pair to take
with me to Australia. They're great.
Check them out. [inaudible] dot com
forward slash. Tim and until next time,
thank you for listening.